they got him ladies and gentlemen Ray
Epps has finally been charged with one
misdemeanor count of disorderly conduct
in a restricted area so and they're
saying it's he's basically taking a plea
deal I imagine he'll get a slap on the
wrist maybe he won't even get any jail
time and you know they did finally
charge him and now you're getting this
narrative from the media as if like this
proves it you see he's he's being
charged too but all that's really
happening is is all the people who
already thought he was a Fed now doubly
think he was a Fed because he's getting
a slap on the wrist one misdemeanor
charge despite the fact he is on camera
telling people to go in the capital and
he is there at the breaching of the
front barricades he told his nephew he
orchestrated it he even explained how
they're at the barricades and a female
cop gets knocked over and he goes I
don't want anyone to think I'm part of
this I'm going to storm forward or
something that effect and nobody's
buying it but it's an interesting story
so we'll talk about that and then we got
another weird story
um um
uh a Democrat I I I don't even know how
to say this Democrats gave an interview
The Washington Post
and one of them said Joe Biden's death
is imminent due to his old age and
that's like I I have trouble even saying
that like whoa Joe Biden now reportedly
gave an interview where he says he fears
his end may be soon as well and it's
he's not going to live long enough to
see Hunter Biden's legal issues resolved
Hunter Biden was about to give a plea
agree take a plea deal I mean we're
talking about relatively soon that's
crazy thing to say and then of course
Russell Brandis on the news because in
the most absurd and shocking story I
guess we have today YouTube demonetized
Russell Brand
for no reason none he's not he's not
done anything wrong he's been accused by
some people he didn't do anything on
YouTube doesn't matter apparently
they're unpersoning him but before we
get started my friends we're gonna talk
about all that head over to timcast.com
click the menu bar and go to timcastirlx
Miami and we have a big announcement
it's it's good news and there's bad news
get your tickets to the Tim cast my uh
Miami event the bad news is I believe
right now we're just sorting the stuff
out Donald Trump Jr is not going to be
able to make it he's very very busy man
however James O'Keefe is going to be
able to make it he's going to be joining
us on stage and I'll also add that while
uh we have James confirmed we have a lot
more people who are going to be there as
well so I you know just more more names
to to come
sorry to everybody who was really
looking forward to seeing uh Donald
Trump Jr I look when when these things
come up they come up and I can't blame
them I appreciate that they were going
to be uh that he was uh going to come
but uh James O'Keefe is going to be here
and I think it's going to be a really
great show so for those that are still
interested in coming down hanging out
with everybody get your tickets now at
timcast.com and of course we're gonna
have the 3 P.M meet and greet for our
timcast.com Elite members check that out
and also in the menu bar click join us
become a member because we're gonna have
a members only uncensored show tonight
and as members you get to call in and
submit questions to us and our guests
actually talk to us by joining our
Discord server so when you sign up you
join the Discord server
you can be in in groups full of
like-minded individuals they do
pre-shows they do after shows and this
is all just the community and then once
you're in the Discord you can actually
submit questions so definitely do that
support our work directly at timcast.com
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show right now with
all your friends because we got a good
show tonight joining us to talk about
this and so much more is the legendary
Kevin Sorbo it's good to be here it's
great to have you watching you man this
is a good show I love it I was honored
to be uh be invited so this is cool it's
an honor to have you we were of course
all of us here were just talking about
all the work you've done especially some
of the huge shows you've done before the
show even started and I feel kind of bad
we didn't record it because you're
talking about shooting schedules and I
mean you've been in so much stuff uh
most of us have seen as and everyone of
course is just saying Hercules Hercules
Hercules thank you Eddie Murphy yes yeah
that's right that's right do you want to
do a quick introduction
uh me yes hi I'm Kevin Sorbo and uh it's
really it's really cool to be here I got
a lot of good stuff coming on the
pipeline as well I got a new movie to
talk about a new book to talk about all
good stuff lots of lots of different
stories about acting tonight I hope I
want to hear I want to hear also we'll
get into it inside baseball inside okay
yeah all right uh hello guys if uh if
you see me here Brett dasovic I am the
host of Pop Culture crisis right here on
YouTube 3 P.M Eastern Standard Time I'm
Ian Crossland you got the uh the test of
lionhood there behind you that's your
newest book I do in Bray books I'm
following the steps of Bethany Hamilton
and uh all those that I cook Cameron a
lot of people have done these books it's
it's kind of cool that I got my own it
just came out this month I'm gonna ask
you about it on the show all right so
let's go to it Carter Banks
how's it going everyone I am filling in
for Surge and I'm excited for tonight so
let's get into it right on let's jump
into this first big story from CBS News
Ray Epps protester at Center of January
6th far right conspiracy charged over
Capital Riot and you see most people are
only going to see the headline and the
goal of this charge in my opinion
it's just it's obfuscation it's you know
the average person's gonna be like what
that guy he was criminally charged yeah
but come on here's the story Ray apps a
former Marine Trump supporter who became
the center of the January 6th conspiracy
theory has been charged in connection
with the Insurrection I like to call it
that according to court documents filed
by the Department of Justice Epps is
charged with disorderly or disruptive
conduct on restricted grounds he's
expected to appear in court Wednesday
for a plea agreement so let's just uh
let's just point something out
the FBI said Ray apps has never been an
FBI Source or an FBI employee I always
take issue with very specific answers
that nobody asked right because the
appropriate answer to the question of
was Ray apps involved with law
enforcement is Ray apps has zero
involvement or interaction with anyone
in law enforcement we don't know this
guy let's just make it unequivocally
clear this guy has nothing to do with us
or any other agency that we know of
instead it's like he wasn't a source or
an employee okay was he informant was he
a contractor well come on did he become
an informant later on I mean look I I
don't want to be too conspirators
because they didn't give a good enough
statement or a clear enough statement
but the issue I see here is you've got
people like Owen Shroyer who's being
sentenced as he was sentenced to 60 days
in prison and the federal government
cited his speech before during and after
his speech after the fact was cause for
him to go to prison but Ray Epps on the
day of telling people to go to the
Capitol and the night before saying to
go into the capital doesn't matter at
all in ascendancing to be there at the
front lines tearing down the barricades
he wasn't the one who physically did it
but the people in front of him dead he
whispered the guy's ear he tears it down
then they Rush In And they're like one
charge meanwhile there's a journalist
named Stephen Stephen horn I believe his
name is four charges and he was and he
was just convicted and will not be
sentenced to prison
so something doesn't add up I don't know
what it is you know I'm not saying this
guy is a fed or anything like that I'm
just saying something is weird about
this story do they come from are there
different prosecutors going after these
people like because these are all spread
out over time right these these
convictions or these uh I mean it's been
two and a half years yeah so there are
different prosecutors and different
judges yeah yeah so does could that play
a role in here is there is there
something to do with leniency or such in
sentencing for these things I I really
doubt it I mean look you've got people
who walked on the grass confused who
were charged and and sentenced to a
month or two you've got you've got uh uh
uh what's I'm forgetting John strand I
think his name was am I getting his name
wrong hopefully I'm not getting his name
wrong sure three years convicted he was
there as a security guard working for Dr
Simone gold he wasn't there in any
political capacity he was just walking
around as a security guard
and they gave him three years yet
they're and and they're gonna give this
guy one charge we didn't tario get like
20 20. he wasn't even there yeah and he
got like a bunch of years in prison yeah
is what they do though you know I'm
gonna use the word lot probably tonight
but hypocrisy is the rule of the day for
these people and you got so much stuff
on this guy yeah so much stuff on him
the video footage is undeniable and yet
one charge he's gonna slap on the rest
nothing will happen to him it's just
that drives me crazy what's going on in
our country right now I would have
thought they would have arrested him and
then made it been like we're charging
him we're giving him 20 years and then
like steal him out of prison in the
night and send him to an island to live
forever like didn't they used to do that
they'd put people in witness protection
or something if they use them for a
purpose but this maybe they just feel
like with internet they can't you can't
hide people anymore you can't track it
so let's just blatantly use this guy to
incite I'm this is a guess but if he's
he's on the floor inciting and he didn't
get the book thrown at him there's
something going on and it just smells
like a some sort of red flag
maybe the conspiracy is because here's
my issue with conspiracy theories
everybody just assumes they know what
the outcome is but you don't so there's
the first thing is people are like okay
something doesn't make sense here and
then they say okay now I know for sure
what the answer is no no here's a
conspiracy theory for you the fed's
intentionally under charged the guy to
make him the focal point of conspiracy
theories so that people aren't actually
looking at who may have really been
there there's a video from one
journalist showing a guy breaking out a
window and then as soon as the guy
realizes being filmed immediately stops
and then starts pushing someone else
accusing the other guy of breaking the
window like you see that one's more
interesting to me right UPS is on camera
saying stupid things if he was actually
an informant or fed or some kind of
plant or provocateur he would not be on
camera doing these things and then you
have other people who are on camera
doing things who get scared the moment
they realize they're being filmed and
stop yeah that is more those are the
ones you got to watch but I mean look if
someone if someone is there either as a
professor Couture or an intentional
rioter or maybe even insurrectionist
they're going to be if they're smashing
out a window they're going to stop and
then act like they weren't doing
anything wrong because they don't want
to get in trouble right it doesn't
matter if you're a fed or not I just
think it's weird that Ray apps would
would just stand there while people are
filming him outright saying constantly
be but what about the woman that got
shot let's just sort of disappeared too
she was doing nothing Ashley yeah and
she gets shot and killed and the video
footage of her she wasn't doing anything
and nothing happened to the gentleman
that shot her I was right I think he had
a promotion I think he probably did yeah
the argument it's like the studio Chiefs
in Universal they just they fail
upwardly but go ahead
uh that she was all having climbing over
a barricade so threatening their she
wasn't climbing over a barricade she was
looking through a window yeah she
climbed up she stood on she stood on the
uh like framing of the window and then
looked through the window and then it
was like they put a button a broken
window so there's like a hole they
probably thought she was climbing
through I mean I don't want any
questions the window was not that big
her face could barely be seen through it
they put a bullet in her neck there's no
reason the guy the guy the cop was
panicked and freaked out it's it's
dangerous to have people like that
holding weapons but these are the things
that happen I didn't hear any defund the
police calls after that one surprisingly
dude the raps think it's the most nuts I
mean just beyond nuts thing this guy's
screaming for people to go to the
Capitol to get Rowdy I don't know all
the quotes but some of the stuff you
mentioned he texted his nephew saying he
orchestrated it
what in the hell he's like yep and uh he
even says in one of the videos he he's
like he doesn't want to say it because
he'll get arrested but he's gonna say it
anyway it's like okay and then he took
him two and a half years to get one
misdemeanor charge you have people you
had that lady I love referencing this
the the feds broke into they stormed
into her house in Alaska because she
looked like a different lady
so there was a woman who was in the
Capitol they were like hey we think this
is the person so they break into this
other lady's house but the guy who's on
camera and citing everybody to do it
it's like nah no no worries here man
how long ago was he charged like
initially charged right absolutely yeah
today it was just today right so is it
possible that he's going to end up uh
informing I think I think the potential
the reality here may be he's been in
informant the whole time the whole time
and uh maybe not for the FBI or
something like that it could be it could
be Capital police and so the FBI says
he's never been a source or an employee
what does source mean does source
include informant it's an opinion
statement so it could or could not their
their quotes meaningless to me but it
could have been the Capitol Police I I
wonder if it's possible because he used
to be an oath keeper if you know
originally he was on the website for
like people of Interest they were
looking for and took him off I wonder if
they found him right away they found him
right away here's he's on camera
everywhere saying this they instantly
are like we got a clear picture of his
face then they went to him and said you
are going to inform and provide
testimony on all these people that
bolster our cases or you're going to go
to prison forever and he said I'll do
whatever you okay I didn't know he was
an oath keeper before that makes a lot
of sense yeah
so what about what about all these guys
I mean the little segue but still on the
same track of what you know what
happened January 6. all these antifa
guys the video footage of them changing
in the clothes and doing Trump closing I
saw a lot of that footage I don't know
if that's real or I've seen the footage
too but I don't know what it is and
these are these are the challenges right
you've got the the pipe bomb guy and
everybody found you've got the video of
changing their clothes and putting on
you know like they're they're taking off
hoodies and putting on like Trump
Trump's looking clothes and there's no
motivation for prosecutors to want to do
anything about it because that's not the
way that the political winds are blowing
right now the political Winds Don't Blow
That Way in general ever yeah no
so there you go I don't know man uh this
is only resulting in more people
believing that there's a conspiracy
theory here but I wonder if if you're
gonna actually believe that the
intelligence agencies are capable of
doing anything you have to operate the
assumption that they're going to be a
little bit smarter it's not like a
random guy just being like I know let's
let's have our friends smash a window
and then we can blame other people for
it and there's gonna be a little bit
more to it than that in which case the
right app stuff is a very very Hefty
distraction everybody's pointing the
finger at this guy and he's just
as far as we can see a doofy trump
supporter who for some reason is not
getting prosecuted and so maybe in his
mind he's like why is everyone coming
after me and if there really was an
intelligence operation you've got guys
like you mentioned changing their
clothes yeah and everyone's just like
raps raps raps well there's a lot of uh
FBI guys apparently right yeah I mean
they were widely reported especially
with the proud boys like dozens I don't
know what the exact number is but FBI
informants up the Wazoo with the proud
boys high level I blame Trump I mean you
saw him speaking he's on camera saying
go peacefully if you're gonna go down
there he didn't say anything about
rioting and if he still gets blame for
it doesn't matter because they just they
go after everything for him I mean he
said seven straight years of being
attacked it's pretty incredible to have
that much hate centered on you for that
long it's incredible yeah Dark Days man
because you look at the stuff going on
there's this guy Stephen horn journalist
objectively a journalist and I mean like
he's not I'm not saying objective
journals I'm saying objectively when you
look at the facts as a journalist and I
guess they got him because when he was
in he went in the capital filming and he
chanted USA USA USA oh now he's
demonstrating so they got him they got
four charges uh entering a remaining
restricted area disorderly disruptive
conduct and restricted area disorderly
conducting a capital building parading
demonstrating or picketing in a capitol
building so to be fair he was in the
Capitol building and so you might say
those two charges related to being
inside rayaps is not going to get but
Ray app still only got one charge he
didn't he didn't even get charged with
entering restricted area despite the
fact he incited everyone to go do it in
the first place
it feels like that's the more serious
charge right would be the incitement of
others to do so because they seem to use
that as their kind of barometer for
where to charge right it's inciting an
Insurrection so if the guy's got if he's
actually saying he orchestrated this
stuff they can't they can't charge him
you know why because Trump's the one in
their minds or Trump's the one they need
to have legally on the books as having
orchestrated it that's what I'm saying
because like when when they were talking
about initially like you said when
they're ignoring what his actual words
were and they're saying that he incited
that's the language they kept using
right he was inciting an Insurrection
this could be the reason why they don't
charge him and they're or they're
holding off on charging them because
they know the evidence would show he not
only admitted to orchestrating it and
attacks between a family member but he's
on camera and citing people and they
need Trump to have been the guy so they
can get him off the ballot yeah they'll
just end up in the same cell together
him and Trump and uh Trump and this guy
will just end up having to serve their
turns I don't know what they're gonna do
with Trump you can't put them in prison
but they can't they're not going to let
him run like they're not going to let
him win I don't know do you think he
ends up on the ballot Trump well what
does that mean what state where do you
think that do you think he'll be wrong
Trump will be removed from I don't know
about enough isn't it doesn't matter
Trump I I believe it is a high
probability Trump is removed from from
the ballot somewhere really yeah I mean
look at I mean Arizona wouldn't it would
not surprise me if come October of next
year Trump's name is just not on the
ball in Arizona because we know they
print with Kate with uh with the uh
Hobbs versus Lake election the wrong
ballot sizes were printed on the wrong
paper yeah and it jammed up the machines
so if they can do that and then go
Whoopsie Daisy and then nothing happens
there's no reconciliation there's no
accountability at all then well they'll
take Trump's name off somewhere and just
go if you had carrying your show oh yeah
several times she's awesome she's great
she's great and and she does have a
bunch of Victories right now too so I
don't I don't act like nothing's
happening yeah they recently ruled that
the signature verification in Arizona
was well it's unbelievably obvious and
then once again we talked about this
early I was driving in here with with
your with your transportation guy it was
awesome and we talked about the in
craziness of the this male and voting
and neither side is fighting to get rid
of it I don't see I don't see anybody on
the right getting rid of it get rid of
it the Democrats are fighting for it the
Democrats I know yeah but no they want
to keep it right that's what I'm saying
we got to get rid of it the only way
you're gonna have an honest voting is
you vote on the day of election and
that's it yep and you show your bloody
idea there's nothing racist about
showing an ID I mean this whole thing is
just it's mind-boggling you got so many
people millions and tens of millions of
people in this country still let this go
on they let it go on you see it right in
front of your face but they just want to
vote for the same people just because
they get a d by their name or something
it's because most people don't pay
attention at all no they don't yeah they
don't it's they're sheep and I keep
saying we got to wake up the Lions but
this is why you were telling us before
the show that uh they kicked you out of
Hollywood because you're conservative
yeah but this is exactly why I mean you
have the biggest show in the world the
last thing they need is someone as
influential as you speaking to the
regular people who aren't paying
attention and telling them to pay
attention right that's dangerous what
did you do what did you say that people
you know the whole internet thing
started in the mid 90s right You've Got
Mail and it just kind of Grew From there
so I was starting to do my own thing
talking about this how about that so oh
my gosh he's a Christian and a
conservative so apparently that's a
double leper in Hollywood and uh they
called me in and they said we can't work
it anymore and I laughed I said you guys
are the ones screaming for tolerance and
they scream for freedom of speech but we
all know it's a one-way street with
these guys and once again hypocrisy
rules not only Hollywood but Washington
DC so I form sobelstudios.com and I've
been doing my own movie since and
because I do independent movies other
Independent Movie Makers come to me as
well not every movie I've done because
since I got booted in Hollywood I shot
about 50 movies but there's other Indies
that come to me and say hey we we're
with you we stand with you people used
to stop me all the time about Hercules
and Andromeda my two series eighty
percent time now it's God's Not Dead
Soul Surfer what if let there be light
that's what people stop me for now
please make more movies like that yeah
when this happened initially in
Hollywood where was the the biggest
amount of pressure coming from was it
coming from Studio heads was it coming
from agents and managers why was it
coming from other apps I didn't get
details like that but I it it got to a
point that obviously they felt they'd
talk to me about it so I'm thinking it
was coming from Studios and networks and
stuff like that so they they saw it as
uh as bad publicity for them yeah I
think so which is weird because like at
that time we're talking uh 12 12 years
ago this is still a country that would
have had a general amount of
pro-christian values yeah my manager was
great I think she just felt the pressure
and it went along with went along with
the big agent so it's unfortunate and uh
I I kind of laughed at it I said this is
ridiculous but uh you know for for an
industry that's
these liberals need to look up the
definition of the word liberal because
the whole thing about being a liberal is
that everybody's point of view is okay
we're different we Embrace everybody
they don't we have more anger more
hatred all this stuff is just spreading
more divisiveness and that's the world
we're living in right now this is what
wokeness tends to be right right now
they masquerade as opposing racism while
supporting racial segregation they they
say liberal when they're illiberal and
they oppose liberal policies in
classical liberals what's antifa they
say against fascism they're actually the
fascists but here's the funny thing is
they always love it's it it is it is a
fair assessment in my opinion if you
look at antifa through a historical
context by today by what they what they
do today and say they're fascist antifa
starts in Germany as the militant wing
of the Communist party and so they go
the we're not fascist but now you take a
look at how they behave there were a
group of people outside of a hospital
protesting Mass mandates antifa
activists came and started beating them
up so it's like okay if you want to
claim to be a communist or opposing
fascism but you beat people up to
enforce government mandated corporate
activities you're a fascist that's
exactly what they are I just want to
understand what these Mayors and these
governors in these states let them get
away with it I don't I don't get it
because at all yeah well they have to be
I mean you've had politicians say that
they're antifa you've had uh you had in
the uh and you know you said it was an
idea yeah and
you said it in the in the debate against
with Trump wow he said oh it's an idea
oh okay because it's decentralized
therefore you can't you can't pinpoint a
leader burn down people's businesses and
attack people that's an idea you can
pinpoint leaders they have they have
active cells with brand names and brand
websites and the FEDS know and the FEDS
don't do anything but hey man heaven
forbid you stepped on the grass on
January 6 and then they're gonna lock
you up for two years Biden's quote from
that presidential debate in 2020 was
antifa is an idea not an organization so
I was going to agree that emergency for
us it is an idea but it's also an
organization but that's important to buy
it and you just said it was well that's
what I like Mass because they cover
their identity they have chapters in
merch stores but the masks don't even
matter you can go to there there's
different chapters and they will call
themselves brand antifa you know insert
name and you can go to their website you
can see the organizers what do they do
for work oh a lot of these kids are rich
yeah you think so I know for a fact wow
yeah so especially during that by Wall
Street we didn't call them antifa at the
time they were just called the black
block anarchists and that was an unfair
assessment the anarchist got mad at us
they were like those guys are not
anarchists anarchists don't believe in
violence anarchists in the truest sense
of left or right believe in
non-aggression so the dudes wearing all
black going and beating people are
tankies they're Communists and we're
like oh okay you know that's fair but we
didn't call him antifa turns out a lot
of these kids were they're like
brooklynite trust fund kids really they
hate their parents yeah they don't have
to work how how do you how so they're
they're they're angry because their
parents made it in the capitalist system
and they become uh no no no no no
they're they're angry because
so it's it's an oversimplification that
I believe is is an emotional attack that
conservatives will be like oh they
resent you know they got mommy or daddy
issues no the reality is they've never
dealt with hardship so if you grow up in
a world where you don't have to work
because things are given to you when
you're older you look around at people
being hungry and you go why aren't
people giving them things like I was
given things the government should give
them things give them homes and this is
why you know I I really man I see a lot
of a lot of wealthy conservatives being
like my kids never gonna know the
hardship I knew and I'm like okay we're
gonna be a liberal then because they're
they're gonna look at Murdoch's kids
right they're gonna look what they're
doing a fox and you're gonna send them
to the to the same four-year colleges
that will indoctrinate them in the same
way they started kindergarten now
unfortunately but but if you're lucky
enough to keep it off them until until
they go to college they then go to
college and they end up in the exact
same place because you don't want them
to face down any of the hardships these
these these trust fund kids especially
the the wealthier ones and and not
necessarily all millionaires or anything
but coming from upper middle class
families even so they didn't have to
work because they lived with their
parents their their attitude is you know
we've we have to we have we have to
protect the oppressed it's weaponizing
and so what happens is when they don't
want to be the evil oppressor because
they come from wealthy upbringing they
turn into a racial issue they can then
say oh yeah you you're you Ian you're
also an oppressor just like me because
you're white and it's like you know you
could you could be a homeless white dude
and they would be it doesn't matter
we're all oppressors it's like bro your
your parents are millionaires that
homeless guy was a is a veteran who
can't find work and you're claiming that
he's at the same level of power that you
do because they're trying to cover up
the fact that they're rich and they want
more power but ultimately what are they
angry about
when you grow up never having to work
your brain does not comprehend where
food comes from your brain doesn't
comprehend that someone has to do labor
to make it and so in their minds it's
just like you take a look at uh schools
a lot of these kids they go to school
from uh you know kindergarten all the
way till they're 22 to 26 and when they
get out of college at 26 years old
they've never had a job and they've been
told how to do everything normal humans
have to figure things out yeah but these
kids are told to do they get out and
they're like okay someone please tell me
what to do I have no idea what happened
they get their first job and the you'll
they find that the employers say that
they're that they can't figure things
out on their own they need to be given
step-by-step instructions because
they've never actually had to kind of
they never saw the problem they've never
problem solved anything I've experienced
this uh dozens of times in every company
I've worked for college graduates have a
higher uh likelihood of being unable to
solve a problem as opposed to high
school graduates or dropouts
homeschoolers are much better that's
true Did you homeschool were you
homeschooled my own my wife's homeschool
Advocates she's got a number of books on
she travels the country and uh yeah it
makes a big difference one of the
blessings of covid is that families woke
up and saw maybe honey we shouldn't use
the public schools as a babysitting
service yes and they sound crappy that
the school system really is two million
more homes are now homeschooling which
is great and school choice is picking up
I know I know there's some pushback from
some anti-woke personalities but I think
school choice for the most part is a
good idea on its face it looks cool that
you could take a stipend every year
instead of send them to where you have
to send them you get to pick where you
want to send them right great
competition get it out of government's
hands but that will create the
competition now that should help a
little bit but Public School Systems
busted and broken and it's getting worse
and people don't seem to want to care
and parents want to keep using it as a
babysitting service which is too bad
well you made a good point that people
are waking up shocked so many people
talking about this look what they did to
these kids you know I mean look at the
businesses it was it was nuts I was
arguing with someone I never get into I
never get political arguments online
it's like the last thing I do I was
arguing with someone saying that like
there should be
class there should be cameras in every
classroom I've said the same thing a
hundred times right why can't I mean
people are saying especially pro pro
teachers union people saying that's not
necessary why would that be necessary
like do you think cops should have to
wear body cameras no the the cops didn't
think that they should have to wear body
cameras cameras Everest cameras and
casinos and cameras and elevators why
can't they be in a school what what are
they hiding that we can't watch as
parents I mean not even just that but
beyond beyond just what they're hiding
I'm on camera all the time the level of
what they're teaching the kids right the
parents have a right to know uh at what
pace their classrooms are working not
just because they might be teaching them
things that are not that is
inappropriate for their age but also
like are the teachers keeping them up to
date are they classrooms actually be
handled well and those are all questions
but they don't want to actually be held
accountable for that yeah well they're
do it was when the remote learning
started yeah that these teachers there
was a video where they were saying we
can't let parents find out what we're
doing they know what they're doing is
crooked evil they aren't even right now
I just realized that the apples watch
the crazy thing is I was uh somebody was
talking about how
the iPhone does this I don't know if
this is true just this caveat here
because I haven't looked it up but
well let me let me pause I had a phone
it was um I forgot what the phone was
called I think it was like the McLaren
something it was like a one phone and it
had a mechanical front-facing camera in
order to uh turn the front-facing camera
on it would slide up from the top of the
phone okay so one day
while browsing the web it just opens up
and then goes back down
and I'm like why did this website just
activate my front-facing camera and then
deactivate my front-facing camera now on
most phones you can't tell because the
front facing camera is just always
always there staring at you yeah but
various websites so what I was almost
saying is that iPhones for instance when
you're using their apps will take a
picture of your face to see your
reaction whether you're happy sad upset
what's your emotional state because the
AI can track your facial expressions so
when you're using apps it's reading your
face to see how you doing
that Oliver TV sets have cameras in
they're watching us in our living rooms
in our bedrooms I don't know if they
have cameras they have microphones and
the microphones are all recording you 24
7. that's a fact so uh for instance we
have we have a TV downstairs that can be
turned out yeah so uh first caveat not
all TVs but all modern TVs that have
voice command are recording you 24 7.
because here's how it works and this is
true of all your at-home devices and to
a certain degree I believe many of your
phones if you're if your electronic
device has a voice command that means
the microphone has to be listening to
you all the time so that when you speak
the command it turns on yeah now how
does it translate your your speech into
into a command it records what you say
sends it to a private company who then
transcribes it to text sends the text
code back to the app the app then runs
the code the speech as the action
that means and not every single device
but most devices that have voice
activation do it this way some do it by
requiring you to say a phrase three or
three to five times and then it just
uses the wavelength to try and match
them we don't really do that anymore
nowadays yeah they're just all on all
the time recording everything you say
and uh for your at-home device that does
all little Deeds for you there have been
numerous stories where murders have
taken place and the police have gotten
recordings of the murder from the
company who own the device
and then they said oh you know they
don't normally record it was a fluke
here what about the smart home the guy
who lit like in the smart home who said
something racist and then it got like
got locked out of his Amazon account or
something like that do you remember that
I something like that I don't know
something along along those lines but
you know I think what it is is that
eventually we were we became essentially
surrounded by technology and people just
acquiesce this is worse than 1984. yes
like oh yeah people it's all of us
combined when people have just accepted
like look I cannot live without this
technology anymore the world doesn't
allow it I I have to have these apps I
have to have this phone I have to have
this computer and the technology is just
too important to your daily life now you
can't opt out in any reasonable way what
makes it better than 1984 is the
internet because in that book they they
were all top down the news media would
tell them over the TV at least we can
see that we're in something like 1984
and we're all able to talk about it and
it may have been worse before the
internet Let's uh we were talking about
um getting cats from Hollywood let's
talk about this story from NBC News you
YouTube suspends Russell Brand from
making money off his channel the BBC
also pulled some of the British Stars
shows from its streaming services
following rape and sexual assault
allegations against comedian which I
might add are 20 to 10 to 20 years old
he's developed into a wellness and
conspiracy influencer this is
I mean this is it right here this is the
hammer in the nail the final the final
nail you've got people the media saying
all these people are conspiracy
theorists for thinking there's an agenda
against Russell Brand okay you want to
make the argument that the BBC channel
for these networks were like look we
don't know whatever it is you you're
involved with Russell Brand so we're
gonna take your shows down it's our
Network it's our Channel we're taking
your shows down it's like okay that's
shady YouTube suspending monetization
from Russell Brand's Channel makes
literally no sense they didn't suspend
his content they didn't ban his channel
they just disabled ads from his channel
and his channel doesn't break any of the
advertiser rules so for what reason did
YouTube take his money away this just
reeks and this is an another uh I mean
this is it this says outright the
likelihood here is that there is an
agenda to or deperson Russell
Brand oh there's no there's no question
and once again we're now living in the
world that is we are guilty before being
proven innocent when it used to be the
other way around people can say anything
about anybody now and they're going back
what I heard 17 years on him right now
then where was this person 17 years ago
why are we waiting so long to hear what
these people have to say and why do they
have any uh what do they have any room
to stand on when they wait that long
it's ridiculous it's crazy to hear these
stories because it's like what evidence
does anybody have 20 years later I a
thing I say well look what they did
Kavanaugh right you know I'm trying to
put them on the Supreme Court
there's already the text messages the
wonky looking text message that's very
clearly doctored uh from Russell Brand
that the lines don't add up detects
certain different shades is all sorts of
uh not exactly you don't buy it right
you're like did you did you look at that
did you look okay so there's a there's a
text message uh in which he apologizes
to the woman and if you look at it it's
it's missing time stamps the text half
the text isn't bold half the text is not
uh it doesn't align in the left and the
right it's off angle it doesn't say
iMessage rather than text message uh
there's all sorts of problems with it
but it goes beyond that now right we're
past uh yesterday was about guilt or
innocence and in in me two cases you
just don't know like at the end of the
day you're gonna have to take your uh on
what side do you fall and then say look
look I'm never gonna know the answer to
this it's going to be he said she said
so what do you do now we have to ask the
question it's no longer about guilt or
innocence that will be decided uh in the
court of public opinion now now it's
looking like the the government is
looking into possibly charging them who
knows now it's about what are the what's
the Fallout is the timing suspicious the
timing is absolutely suspicious he has
six million followers 6 million
subscribers on YouTube and he speaks out
a lot against Tim you mentioned Ukraine
and War or he's also very much in uh
against big Pharma and in election
cycles that are decided by a few hundred
thousand votes a guy with six million
subscribers who reaches a lot of people
has a lot of pulls so when people say
like it sounds conspiratorial that they
would try to take this guy obviously no
it doesn't like do I buy it no I don't
know for sure but I know that the
government especially our government has
done a lot worse for a lot less well so
here's the issue with your text message
thing at this point all of the media
Outlets that are covering the story have
already created their own Graphics of
those texts so you can't I I can't look
I can't find what you're talking there's
something about this text that someone
pointed out a lawyer I think it was uh
and we can look at this text and read
through this Texas you want the last
thing she writes to him is that she
Prides herself uh she used the wrong
word but on being safe and trying to
make the right decisions obviously this
was a bad one so she's acknowledging
that she made the decision to do what
she did which a lawyer said that that
kind of indicates that it wasn't rape
but it's be but it's beyond the language
it's about the fact that it looks
doctored if there's a but even that way
they're not even talking about anything
specific yeah for all we know he could
be talking about he he had her he was
screaming and ranting about how he was
going to eat 27 milkshakes and then he
had to apologize her because he was like
oh I'm so sorry I behaved that winch
like you freaked me out last night that
was inappropriate she got a rape kit
this girl the next day that same day
yeah she went to a Rape Crisis Center
um she had a kit done she did not choose
to press charges back then and now
they're saying that all of the women
that have come forward one actually is
named
um it escapes so out of five women one
actually gave her name uh and they talk
a lot in the in the segment they're
talking about The Bravery of these women
I said the woman who who gave her name
is is Brave the woman who actually comes
forward and puts herself in the public
eye is Brave the rest of this is like
look we still live in a country that
operates under the premise of Innocence
until proven guilty but they don't need
to do that anymore especially with
figures who go against uh the narrative
that they want to push they can kill you
in the court of public opinion again
well you gotta wonder if they'd be doing
this if he he was on the other side
politically yeah
clearly not okay of course no question
Mike Tyson I know a lot of people like
Mike Tyson he actually he has an actual
rape conviction he is not demonetized on
YouTube Colleen Ballinger who is uh who
is a kids YouTuber who has very very
serious grooming allegations against her
is not demonetized on YouTube there's
all sorts of Youtubers with very very
serious claims made about made against
them that haven't had their channels
demonetized because that shouldn't get
you demonetized it has to be something
that is done in a court of law and it's
third party it's off app Behavior
anyways like they don't really have a
leg to stand on Luke pointed out cardi B
didn't she admit to raping guys no she
she drugged it she drugged and robbed
men who paid her for sex oh okay okay uh
and then a lot of people have a hard
time with that one because they're like
look these guys are suckers they set
themselves up for them like that doesn't
matter there was still something done
against them it's like the party was a
hooker yes uh she was a stripper in a
yes the lady of the night we'll say that
uh and there's just in an industry in an
industry that loves to promote horrible
Behavior here's another thing there's a
there's a show this was a everything
about Russell Brand is coming out on
Channel 4 right now there's a show
called naked education on Channel 4 that
runs right now in which adults stand
naked in front of children so that they
can help destigmatize different body
types am I supposed to buy that channel
4 who runs that show is the Bastion of
good Consciousness I don't think so and
it's uh it's insane uh you don't nobody
deserves to be lectured by these
scumbags well this is like January 6th
it's all selective attacks they just
decide who they want to choose and when
they want to choose and if they're
hurting us we're going to take them down
when they say yes you're talking about
government you're talking about Pharma
companies you're talking about whatever
it may be that is going to be against
the agenda of what the left wants and
when you mention hypocrisy it's exactly
right they don't care if they're
hypocritical no that doesn't matter
there's no truth but Power there's a
great video and I'm sure you've seen
this it's got to be like three four
years ago when Nancy Pelosi's up in
front of the press and say we create a
smear and we tell you about at the press
and then you take it and you make it
real for us have you seen this video
it's unbelievable she oh it's like four
years ago it's up there you can find it
she openly admits that they'll lie and
let the Press you guys our favorite left
wing press you guys will go out there
and make this person's life miserable
it's the presumption of innocence yeah
it's really a center piece of what
allows us to exist as a society is
acknowledging that we're all innocent
until we can somehow get a group of
peers together to to find proof
otherwise but
um that doesn't mean that corporations
don't have immense power and control
over your finances we'll end with cases
like this it plays on our you know our
imminent desire to protect other people
right so it's very very hard to come out
and say to someone like look I can't
take your word for it on something like
this and this was what happened like
there is also it's to your point uh
Danny Masterson who was just convicted
there was no benefit of the doubt given
to him because he's part of the
mainstream and he's uh he's a
Scientologist so he has that working
against him so people are saying you
know lock him up throw away the key with
something like that now we have Russell
Brand and you have to wonder why is he
being targeted the Danny Masterson is
different this is this case it's like
they uh they don't really seem to care
who they go after in these cases and
people get caught in the middle but I
think for brand it's absolutely
politically at least now with the like I
was on the fence yesterday with the
YouTube demonetization his show is
getting canceled now all his uh
stand-ups have been put on indefinite
hold his book deal has been put on
indefinite hold it feels extremely
coordinated
agreed
seriously it's just it's it's what we're
doing in this country right now and
going after people for no reason
whatsoever and uh they they it's a power
trip and it's power gain this country's
socialist now and they want to keep
working down that wrong road I think the
funny thing about this is you know when
you when you look at the story and the
allegations made against Russell Brand
it's like okay you know all right let's
let's let's say these accusations are
correct whatever uh they didn't care at
all back then because he was on their
team and now that he's
anti-establishment anti-war it's like
what do we got 20 years ago fire away
huh well look how long it took to get
Harvey Weinstein right yeah they
protected they all knew it Oprah was
protect them all kinds of people and
that was going on Seth MacFarlane made
jokes about it and I think it was
Courtney Love Too right Courtney Love
said don't no she she wasn't making
jokes she was asking she's like don't go
don't go into a hotel room with Harvey
wines right they all knew yeah they all
knew they did nothing why because it's
beneficial for him a lot of these women
knowingly went with him too knowing that
they were like this is a path to power
and fame there have also been like there
have been women that are coming out and
saying like I've had no bad experiences
with Russell Brandon then people are
like well what does that matter because
these accusations say he doesn't like
exactly that does not hold any more
weight than that in this in this case
outside of the fact that you can't prove
in a court of law that any of this
happened what is a general person
supposed to do in this other than say I
don't know maybe maybe not and YouTube
should not I I want I think I think
Russell Brand should sue Google
for uh like breach of contract or
something people need people people need
to understand that uh the agreements
that you have when you sign up for one
of these Services is a mutual contract
they tend to be of course obviously very
favorable to the corporation because not
like you get a red line and send it back
or anything like that but
Russell Brand's got a monetary deal with
YouTube he produces they run ads they
split they split the money in a certain
percentage if YouTube is going to
arbitrarily shut his channel down when
he broke no rules I think he I I I'm not
a lawyer but I think that there is a uh
a claim here because YouTube is going to
have to justify in court that for no
reason at all or actually this is
different they these contracts always
say we can terminate your account for no
reason and there's questions in certain
States or wherever United States whether
or not that matters especially when
YouTube is now saying they suspended
Russell Brand because of the allegations
yeah when they said offline Behavior now
they've given a reason now Russell Brand
can cite that reason as a potential
violation of the contract and this has
been going on Beyond just YouTube I mean
patreon has been doing this to people
for years uh kicking them off the
platform because of off you know
off-brand behavior and stuff on platform
platform Behavior but also like not just
that but like we had videos so Me Andy
Senora had videos that were all
demonetized or at least limited ad
Revenue just talking about it and there
was nothing in the language in any of
our titles nothing in any of our
thumbnails that would have triggered
anything like that and that's a problem
when they're clearly if you look up
anything to do with Russell Brand now on
YouTube now maybe it's different now but
for as of four hours ago before we went
live I I saw you covered it this morning
right and that by the time we went live
your video had 88 000 views at that time
right and the nearest one that I saw in
the top five to six search results on
YouTube was about forty four thousand I
think that was from the USA Today or
something like that but that was from
yesterday now every single one on the
entire first page of search results were
all what they call authoritative news
sources so you're only getting one side
of the story anyways my video on the
Russell Brand Story got as of this
morning 300 so it got 310 000 views and
I'm just talking about your demonetized
one I'm just talking about the one from
this morning no I'm saying talking about
his demons right right that one had more
views than the highest viewed of any of
the mainstream news sources on that
first page nowhere to be seen because
they want to be able to control who sees
what and who gets what information for
people who are listening uh and I'll
tell you I think if YouTube had their
way this show would not exist but they
but the thing that YouTube does is
suppression and removal from the
algorithm and the problem that they're
facing is people choose to watch this
show knowingly which means for a lot of
people who produce content it's the
front page recommendation where people
will find the content and that's true
for a lot of the clips we produce on
this show and the clips we produce
viewership is lower than it used to be
because they have been suppressing us
and we get a lot of people who message
us saying like your the live show didn't
appear today I had to type it in and
find it and I'm like that's right but
it's really hard so they they they they
they try to be careful because
they don't want to do outright no reason
bans of big content because it creates a
PR storm and potential legal issues so
they go for the suppression route and
hope that you eventually Fade Into
Obscurity and then cease to exist sure
but if that's what Facebook did to me
right but if people watching this show
share the URL
and then through text messages through
acts through whatever YouTube can remove
it from the front page or sometimes
people tell us they'll go to youtube.com
timcastirl it doesn't even appear on the
channel page like we will have people
who say it's not even on the live do you
ever contact them and say what are you
guys doing why is that they say oops
Yeah whoops oh yeah Whoopsie Daisy well
that's Hollywood Creative Accounting as
well that's right you'll find their
their you know if you make a back-end
deal in Hollywood that means you're
pretty much gonna take in the back end
because everything they can not to pay
you yeah and it is they even coined the
term uh Creative Accounting yeah if you
listen to anybody in these Studios
they're going to say any show didn't
make any money yeah they're just gonna
say until you come after them Disney
movies movies are all bankrupt oh
they're they wouldn't make any money but
we just keep making movies out of the
goodness of our heart but it's just
amazing but for YouTube to take him down
and stop and stop him from making money
and to me already says oh he's guilty
and this is what's going on right now
we're saying people are guilty before
they do it and Hollywood's gonna keep
doing that I love them Ricky Gervais got
up what is it was it was it the golden
than globes he hosted like four years in
a row yeah he even said to Hollywood he
goes he goes if the Taliban had a film
fund you'd be the first people you know
to sign up yep because because that's
what they do he uh also I guess it is
fair to point out that he's not he's not
banned from YouTube he's just
demonetized which is just to
disincentivize him from using it but
hopefully Rumble will get something
demonetizing reduces your viewership in
the algorithm so this has long been the
case I don't know I I can't speak to
what YouTube's algorithm is definitively
I don't know but it has long been the
case that many of the research
scientists who use YouTube and a lot of
these there are a lot of people who like
try and track and figure out how YouTube
works if you are not running ads in your
content YouTube is less likely to show
your content duh YouTube's gonna be like
hey if you don't put ads in your content
we don't make money from it it costs us
money so we're not going to show it yeah
so if they demonetize brand they're
likely going to stop showing his videos
in the recommended feed or whatever but
like they were for the most part anyway
and this is the issue with the with a
potential agenda against Russell Brand
he's too famous he's got what does he
have 12 million followers or whatever on
X yeah he's got six million on YouTube
and he's anti-ukraine War a lot of
people think they're going after Russell
Brand because of the covid video where
he talks about big Pharma and I'm like
ah look man you go after a big
Corporation they smear you you go after
the government by saying no war in
Ukraine and the intelligence agencies
has uh what did what was it Biden who
said this who said this was a Schumer
they got six waves from Sunday to deal
with people like you or something like
that sounds like a Schumer thing yeah
they're talking about Trump so you know
I I'd imagine this has more to do with
the fact that a high profile celebrity
is generating massive opposition to
their war effort in Ukraine and right in
time for the election next year it's
interesting isn't it one year out
remember
they got rid of Alex Jones and Paul just
Watson and Milo and Laura we were and
that's the crazy thing right we were
like when we were talking about this
earlier we were getting everything ready
I'm like who are the people that were
banned like I remember everybody
remembers Alex Jones and it's like this
is the point we couldn't remember him I
couldn't remember Paul Joseph Watson a
guy like I couldn't like didn't come to
my mind because if they get you out of
the algorithm if they get you off the
platforms you're essentially
non-existent now people will forget that
you exist because you're not being seen
on a daily basis I wonder if I wonder
how much time we got left you know here
at uh Tim cast IRL because I mean come
on in 2020 we were getting like a
million plus hits per night and I think
that probably made us one of the biggest
podcasts in the world I mean I mean
during the election cycle specifically
in these like two months I think we had
something like 180 million uh uh views
per month some ridiculous number now
it's like 60. so it's like still really
good really good and as we're entering
2024 it's likely that we're going to get
massive viewership again because we are
the like you know for whatever reason
people like you guys listening you like
watching the show I I imagine that
they're gonna look they got they go with
the biggest voices well they're watching
you that's for sure absolutely suddenly
a bunch of abused chickens are just
going to come out of the woodwork and
we're gonna have to deal with
allegations in the company I don't know
I think it'll just be like what they do
with Crowder right so what there's
nothing to come out against Crowders
like always getting divorced they try
and smear them over that stuff and it's
like you can't there's nothing really
there then some some personal issues but
so what they do is they they give them a
strike from 15 uh from a video 15 months
ago and then oh now you can't stream for
a week and they're just basically
erasing his content very very slowly if
they were to ban Crowder outright they'd
make a huge Splash which would cause PR
problems Death By A Thousand Cuts
exactly yeah slowly slowly over time
they will seek to remove people I think
that that may be considered a human
rights violation in the future for for a
corporation to strip you of your bank
account access or for a company to strip
you of your monetization I think it
should be considered human rights
violation right now but I imagine that
the direction we are going in this
culture war is that they're going to
keep doing it and it won't be a
violation that it could lead towards
that and then there's some sort of
devolvement and dissolution of the human
species and then we have a third world
war and then From the Ashes we create
something where we're like we cannot
make that mistake again it might yes or
it might go the route that we integrate
a digital Human Rights bill well let's
let's jump to this story from the Daily
Mail Biden 80 is worried he might die
before his son Hunter's legal issues are
resolved and think they will get worse
report claims the first thing I want to
add to this story is
Hunter Biden was about to agree to a
plea over these charges which would
resolve his legal issues like you know
right now okay but to be fair maybe what
Joe is saying is that he knows there is
more to come well at any rate we have
this story from the Washington Post
anxiety ripples through the Democratic
party over Biden uh this I'm just gonna
I'm gonna read it for you quote he is in
a period of period of his life oh wait
wait for dramatic effect I'm going to
start over he is in a period of his life
where passing and death is imminent said
Sharon Sweda the leader of the
democratic party in Lorraine County in
Ohio
who said she often hears from voters
worried about the president's potential
Frailty we are all in a ticking clock
but you're in when you're at his age or
at Trump's age that clock is ticking a
little faster and that's a concern for
voters quite literally Biden has
expressed concern he's going to die at
some point soon and I mean he's past the
average life expectancy and a democrat
in Ohio outright said that his death is
imminent and this is based on his old
age
um I I don't know man does does Biden
make it to November does he drop out or
does he drop out dude as I'm watching
and listening to this Destiny video I
mentioned last night where he's becoming
learning all about the barisma stuff
Hunter leaving his laptop at that repair
shop and forgetting about it and then
them seizing the laptop and then
basically leaking the emails and all
this these emails between Hunter Biden
and barisma come out it exposes Joe
Biden's role in basically
I I don't know the right words to use
yeah corruption dude Biden said I've
never talked to my son about business I
don't know his people and all that stuff
and now not only does he talk to his son
about business there are recordings of
it there's emails there's texts Hunter
says my dad takes money from me dude
you've got you've got Devin Archer
saying that this is what they were doing
they were saying was saying that this is
it this is the Biden business it all
came out man and they were not expecting
that I think Biden it's the it is the
stress is crushing his brain like I
remember
um uh what's his name Reagan like became
had Alzheimer's all the stuff and they
were like was he hiding something were
there secrets that he didn't want to
tell about something they were like I
don't remember they were like what do
you remember what that was there was
something I asked him if he could that
if he did something and he was like I
can't remember because of Alzheimer's
and that was convenient it was hitting
his last couple years as president
there's no question about that but Joe's
already there Joe's been there since he
won the presidency I'm sure they're in a
debate so I just jacked them up with B12
just to get them thinking I could not
believe when I saw him actually come out
like talking yeah the amount of like
this guy the amount of corruption that I
don't know if there's Obama that put
Biden as Point man in Ukraine uh and
then Biden decided I'm gonna bribe the
guy you oh really you're gonna make do
some class a felony to bribe this
corrupt uh that's on tape and then he
admits to that he admits to doing the
bribe like what a quid pro quo does
anybody really believe he has no idea
about his son's business dealings I mean
the Ridiculousness of that alone but
they've got they've got there's a list
of all these lies he said you know
apparently he fought in World War one as
well but I mean I don't know it's just
weird what they he gets away with I know
Joe Biden claimed and you're not going
to believe this lie that he's been
serving the United States government for
800 years
yeah yeah he was joking but the thing
they do is Trump will say something
that's obviously not true or it's
hyperbolic or a joke and they'll say it
was a lie instead of course that's the
that's that's the game but the question
here is if Democrats are worried about
the life of Joe Biden and Joe Biden is
worried about the life of Joe Biden
should we as the American people be
concerned about the health of our
president and whether or not he will
remain our president over the short
future because everyone wants Kamala to
take over because remember when she was
running against the other 12 people
during the Democrat primary she was the
first to booted off so 98 of Democrats
didn't want her for president but it's
crazy that they chose her it's it's you
know you know what I think hey they they
put a woman in the Supreme Court that
can't Define what a woman is that's
crazy that's perfect there is there one
theory is that they were going to run
they wanted to run literally anyone the
the article from I think was the
Atlantic is stay alive Joe Biden all we
need is your corporeal form and it's
because people wanted to vote against
Donald Trump so I'm wondering if their
attitudes were like let's pick pick the
worst candidates imaginable and then
make the election only about Donald
Trump but so it was an anti-election but
the barisma stuff I don't think they
knew I think Hunter went in there and
took that job on the board without Joe
knowing because Hunter's such a piece of
trash I don't know he went over there
with Devin Archer and they so then the
president of Ukraine they were like
let's do a deal and they're like not
interested go to Poland and do a deal
with the president of Poland so they go
there president Poland's like Devin you
should go back to Ukraine join the join
the board of barisma Devin's like that's
a good idea so they go back Hunter and
Devin go back to Ukraine
they go to barisma they go to uh
zlachevsky and they're like hey let's I
want to join the board and he's like
interesting idea actually we want you on
the board Hunter some guy that he said
is stupider than his dogs lachesky said
that Hunter is stupider than his dog but
he put him on the board of his Oil
Company the board you need to read to
use him for access to his dad to read
Biden Inc Politico magazine 2019. Biden
knew what Hunter was doing he knew about
the board I wonder if he knew about
everything that Hunter was doing you you
read read the story Biden ink it talks
about 2011 with the Biden family
Fortune's tracking alongside Joe Biden's
career the the the 10 of the big guy
stuff goes well well way earlier than
just 2014 in bursma yeah but I wonder if
Hunters stupidly took this job that
makes no sense it makes an idiot it no
it makes no sense that Joe Biden is
enriching his family and then all of a
sudden one day even though he's the
point guy on Ukraine his son randomly
just goes there it was supposed to be
Devin Devin was supposed to be the board
guy and then they they asked her to do
it Hunter's like yeah definitely yeah
and and they're like what the hell now
the vice president's son's on the board
that's not what we intended that's an
excuse to protect the body I'm just
trying to think about it it could just
be the Joe orchestrated it I don't know
but so either way Hunter is an idiot and
he did a stupid thing by joining that
board when when Joe Biden is put in
charge of these key projects and then
his family starts getting enriched off
of the off of ancillary contracts
related to these projects or government
issues I don't think it's a coincidence
to say that the bidens were doing this
for a long period of time and the one
time it was an accident was barisma
makes no sense I wouldn't call it an
accident I just don't know okay the
Occam's razor suggests that if the
bidens are peddling influence well
before 2014 the barisma deal was part of
that influence peddling that's it Biden
was the point guy on Ukraine he said he
was in the CFR meeting he says I get the
tough assignment so they send me to
Ukraine all of a sudden Hunter Biden's
on the board yeah 10 for the big guy he
knows look at this Biden Inc political
magazine talks about out how his brother
gets lucrative contracts as soon as Joe
Biden's put in charge of Iraq so then he
gets put in charge of Ukraine Hunter
Biden appears on the board of this
Energy company surprise surprise Devon
Archer testifies that when the
prosecutor is investigating Hunter Biden
calls DC asking for help Biden then
flies out within the immediate I think
it was a few days two weeks later two
weeks he makes an email two days later
and then like two weeks after that he
flies out there two weeks after that he
flies out and says fire this prosecutor
that's not a coincidence Biden didn't do
this on accident Hunter wasn't
accidentally there they know exactly
what they're I think it's November 22nd
of 2015 is when Biden flew out there I
thought it was February I don't want to
get the dates wrong here yeah but I'll
reference Destiny's video again at the
end of the at the end of the video all
the data is in it so they're not
Hunter's legal issues they're Biden's
legal issues they're Joe's legal issues
I mean it's both of them man if if they
did that if they colluded together to
sell us out to Ukrainian oil a corrupt
Ukrainian oil company and set us up for
world war three like those guys are
oh no I'll let the public and the courts
decide no honest person who knows the
story and the facts
would tell you that Joe Biden is
innocent because there is no
circumstance I mean we're talking like
the the likelihood that all of these
things happen as Joe Biden describes
them despite all of his lies so far on
it it's just by by 10 lottery tickets
buy buy a lottery ticket for every
different major Lottery game and win all
of them good luck I got the feeling that
uh Obama was like Joe you're taking
Ukraine you're the point man and Joe's
like I'm gonna go fight those Soviets
I'm going out there I'm gonna stop I'm
gonna protect us from the Soviets and
this whole thing's been like yo bro the
Communists are in our country Joe
they're not over there the Communists
are gone from stop defending Joe Biden
no I'm trying to understand Joe Biden I
can very easily the the idea that Joe
Biden was like I'm gonna go to Ukraine
to do something good to help America
isn't it insane view to have based on
all the facts that we already have yeah
look at this story I mean Politico
reports this in 2019 over as decades in
office middle class Joe's family
fortunes have closely tracked his
political career they had this really
amazing video breaking it all down where
they actually show if it even loads
paradigms that you they actually let me
see if I can jump to uh one of these
images it shows a timeline and this is
this is Politico Politico is not a
right-wing publication
you should you guys should watch this
actually yeah this works I can uh it's
not let me scroll
they talk about let me see if I can pull
up uh
if you talk about Iraq during Obama year
several months after James joined a
construction firm as executive The Firm
received a contract worth more than a
billion dollars to build houses in Iraq
while Joe oversaw the U.S led occupation
of that country along the way James
partnered with his nephew Hunter the
younger of Joe's two sons a graduate of
Georgetown yeah blah blah blah struggled
with substance abuse et cetera et cetera
et cetera they've been documenting this
this has long been documented we know
this is the case the idea that well
before Ukraine we're talking Iraq we're
talking 20 2011.
the idea that his brother is getting
these lucrative contracts and that Joe
is overseeing the government operations
and his brothers now getting getting the
corporate capitalist contracts that when
it came to Ukraine it's the one time Joe
Biden was like I'm gonna go do good to
fight Soviets no he was like what's my
assignment Obama uh Barack and Brock's
like take care of you crying and he goes
all right hey hey uh Devin and Hunter
how can we make money off this I'm in
charge now on the bus
there you go that's the Biden family I
believe that they did do that uh whether
Joe instigated it or Hunter instigated I
don't know but I think you know they say
the evil people think they're doing good
I I think that he's justifying like he's
actually fighting the Communists no way
dude protecting us from the Soviets
you're talking about the distinction
between you're talking about the
distinction between lawful good and I'm
sorry lawful evil and catech evil Joe
Biden is chaotic evil he does or maybe
maybe neutral evil or or actually no
that's completely wrong you've got the
the people who uh lawful man how do you
break this down lawful good could be
evil following the law to be good or I
guess you'd call that lawful zealous
paladins man they're dangerous right
they have to do good no matter what Joe
Biden's the guy who's like I'm doing
good for my family nothing else matters
so you can argue that he thinks he's
doing good by enriching his family
because that's all this world is there
was I talked about this earlier today
when I was doing a video on uh uh it was
the video on Russell Brand you uh you
have these videos there's a video that
went viral the hyenas he eating like a
wildebeest or something alive they're
disembowling it as it struggles to get
up and they said the the idea that the
world is fair is incorrect In fact it is
the most uh vicious uh of aggressors
that succeed and are rewarded for their
actions Joe Biden probably has the
predator mindset yeah he does and so his
attitude is you don't matter
all that matters is that he gets power
from whatever whatever he can and if you
talk to him he'd be like geopolitics is
a dirty game like that's how he'd
justify it well all I can say is this is
very disappointing next thing you tell
me Nancy Pelosi has you know she can
manipulate the stock market no I don't
think she has any ability to uh oh yes
she does insider trading if you have
that like Nancy Pelosi's stock track
stock tracker that exists where it's
like yeah you want to get rich I was
being sarcastic by the way
I mean if you're looking for a financial
advisor I'd recommend reaching out to
the financial advisors of members of
Congress yes figure out which company
Nancy Pelosi is using to handle her
deals and just say hey look whatever
Nancy does that's what I'm doing I think
oh that's cool
Inconvenient Truth all you do when Al
Gore came out you should invested in
everything he put his money into with
this whole climate change things he made
a lot of money yeah fauci made a couple
million bucks I think I'll give you a
couple million couple million on top of
the book deal yeah this I think that
Biden's brain has been destroyed by this
Hunter's reveal by the laptop getting
revealed because it basically implicates
the entire Biden family like Hunter and
Joe with all this criminal corruption
working with uh barisma it's disgust I
mean and I think that his brain is so
did he get in the Georgetown on his
grades or was it because of his name of
uh uh Hunter yeah I don't know they said
he has a law degree I have no idea what
the hell's going on all right you guys
talked about that all right you guys we
we know that Joe is is corrupt but we
have to talk about this this video right
here have you guys seen this one I need
I need your help Joe Biden was giving a
speech to the U.N general assembly and
he said some words I think
and I don't know what he said
I will play the video for you now
we're going to ask the Evolve our
institutions
and drive creative new Partnerships let
me be clear
certain principles are in the National
system are sacrosanct okay I caught some
of that but wow well let's try that
again play it again I mean it has the
involve our institutions
institutions something about our
institutions
and he said let me be clear and you
heard a couple of people laugh
all right here we go
I really asking of our institutions
and drive creative new Partnerships let
me be clear
[Laughter]
wait wait hold on they were too high I
want I want to assume they were it was a
cough but we're gonna play okay here we
go
how many times do you evolve our
institutions and drive creative new
Partnerships let me be clear
certain principles
but it but it also sounds like a huh I
think it's like are you kidding me kind
of laughs what what was I I literally
I'm deaf in one ear so maybe I'm
struggling really hard here but like I
have no idea what the first phrase hey
look I deciphered tuna Nash habit of
pressure
bit of pressure and we think what he was
saying was true International
cooperation under pressure
okay he's also said battle calf care and
next now recent I have no idea what
those things are that's a new uh drug
because they just take a bunch of
letters and throw it together because
every other commercial on TV if you know
there's no reason there's yet another
Direction I mean like a drug yeah next
not resin sounds like a trick but this
one with only 47 side effects this one
listen listen
involver institution
I recognize something is that what he's
saying
now it has the Ebola institution a
reasor is our institutions wow
but look look Mitch McConnell freezes
but it's almost sad
no it is it's sad Mitch McConnell free
Mitch McConnell freezes and then
everyone's like whoa he's not doing
anything it's major news because it's
shocking Biden figured it out mutter
incoherently and what happens is the
journalists are too embarrassed to ask
did I misinterpret what he said so with
you know McConnell paralyzed or whatever
having a stroke or whatever just having
everyone agrees something bad happened
but do you want to be the one person in
the room to go what what did Biden just
say and they're gonna go did you not
hear him I'm not here to do your job for
you also people that don't speak English
but somewhere some will but there's got
to be of the 95 of liberal journalists
don't they don't you think someone's
guy's been closed doors going yes or can
we not see the sign language
interpreters like why doesn't one come
out of their closet it's well no no it's
because what happens is these these uh
corporate journalists after Biden gives
a speech and they take notes they walk
into the back room say say I have no
idea what he just said so you tell me
and then they they look over at their
CIA Handler who then says here's the
quote and then they just type whatever
whatever they're told by the Intel
agencies there you go that's that's
there you go what is like the sign
language interpreter they have sign
language interpreters of that events
were they just standing there like what
did he say no they probably just went
like this that's the university
that's a good one that's crazy man this
is the president of the United States
like a horror movie I mean it's really
scary when they wheel her in I mean it's
sad we can talk all about the cultural
decay in this country and you know the
potential for conflict or whatever's
going on but let's just be real like one
of the biggest existential threats we're
facing is our decrepit aging political
class and their their inability to
relinquish any power well left more than
anybody was screaming about these
another old age old guys in office and
who do they put in office I mean they
still voted for the guy yeah Trump's 77
too to be fair he's old
they're all a lot more energy yeah I I
say this like Trump is a fry you know
what I mean no Trump has this video
where he like hits a golf ball up and
then catches it and everyone's like yeah
you know he may be out of shape but
Biden's busted did you see that picture
of Joe Biden stretching and the guy's
like it's Joe Biden stretching before
running and they're like Trump couldn't
do this
he's like Trump couldn't do this Joe
Biden does all sorts of stuff I have
golf with President Trump I gotta tell
you it's a pretty good golf ball pretty
good that's pretty good yeah it's an
example of how solar age and genetic age
are not the same like you can go around
the Sun a hundred times and you still
have a healthy youthful body okay
and talk about a guy with a lot of
energy let's let's play this Harry says
in video I have a lot of things to say
about this guy just out of curiosity for
all the Trump supporters and Republicans
do you think that Donald Trump could do
something like this
what is he doing President Biden was
this is President Biden out in Delaware
recently exercising with first lady Jill
Biden and I saw this photo I was like
wow that's pretty impressive for Joker
yeah you know what and I thought like
that is impressive for you and I agree
anybody really think that Trump could
match this
and also do these Trump supporters think
that Trump could ride a bike
like do you can always imagine that and
this photo proves a lot to me not only
is Joe Biden more mentally fit to be
president but he's also more physically
fit to the president you know
Republicans always want to talk about
Biden's Fitness truly is liberalism
truly is the sickness but it the problem
they want you to say liberalism but it's
not liberalism this is like I I'm sorry
dude look I'm an old man I guess I'm 37.
I wish I was right but when I was
growing up the kid who acted like this
was like the weirdo I don't know what
neighborhood he's from maybe in the
suburbs that's what it's all about the
like he would be made he would be the
nerd who get bullied and if you if if
that was the kind of if the way dude I'm
just saying you go to my where where my
high school was I was only there for two
months but if a kid like that was
standing around being like you know but
Bill Clinton was really good you guys
can can George W bush Al Gore is gonna
be like dude he'd get he'd get picked on
sorry you're a kid why do you care about
I know it's a horrible he's like 20
something oh yeah plus like he's he's
being paid for it right this is can we
watch the whole bike video like you
can't win my job I didn't fell down
right dude Joe Biden fell up the stairs
how many videos you got to show them
walking around not knowing where to go
when it gets off of stage speaking or
shaking shaking hands at the air yeah
but I'll just I'll just say this it's
weird that he's like can Trump do this
and I'm like probably not next question
yeah I don't understand what that has to
do with anything I care about yeah man
the conflation between Biden and Trump
anytime someone in a conversation about
Biden brings up Donald Trump or vice
versa talking about Donald Trump and
someone brings up Joe Biden you gotta
not dismiss it but
realize that that's a moronic conflation
of data it has nothing to do with it I
know Hillary Clinton can do that all
right
look even better now after that video of
him playing tennis with Jake Paul oh
right he's like actually in in pretty
good shape so look I'm not voting for
Trump or anybody based on whether or not
they can stretch their what muscle is
that that's the hamstrings in the back
isn't it that's it maybe yeah I thought
I thought that that's what it was it
could be um he might be doing a
sartorial story to decide you know
Sartorius but uh I I really don't care
if Trump can do that I really don't care
if Trump can say trinity National
pressure all that matters to me is that
Trump is the one guy with the highest
probability of just firing random people
and and cutting down these bureaucracies
for the longest time Republicans have
been like smaller government smaller
government than they spend more money
they bring more people they don't reduce
the government I'm just hoping that
Donald Trump is a guy who goes in for
revenge and just starts firing people in
which case Harry dude I literally
wouldn't care if Joe Biden did a
roundoff back layout I would be like wow
that's really cool where do I vote for
Trump it's meaningless Trump trump could
be sitting in a wheelchair eating a box
of Krispy Kremes with icing and custard
all over his face and I would still be
like
he's gonna pay more likely to fire
people and that's all I can say I'm like
I'm not happy with any of it hey he made
us energy independent right and now as
soon as Trump I mean as soon as biting
on office he said no we're going to cut
off the oil supply here let's buy oil
from countries that hate us
and gas goes to seven bucks a gallon
yeah it's getting crazy don't pay
attention to that but that's that's the
point because the mechanism of the uh
American energy or military I should say
the Petro dollar is we need to be
dependent on others so that they don't
stop being customers for us right the
reason we give millions of dollars to
gender studies programs in Pakistan is
so that they have money to spend so that
they spend it it's really that simple
you give the money to someone Pakistan
is a choice they could trade in one or
they can trade in dollars so we go to
them and say hey we're gonna give you 12
million dollars for gender studies I
don't care what you do with it and then
they're gonna they're gonna pad their
their bank accounts they're gonna steal
that money but that ensures that they're
gonna be like no no we trading dollars
so when China comes to them and says no
no no trading dollars trade and one
they're gonna be like oh he's got 12
million dollars if we keep trading in
this we're rich for free screw off
that's that's the name of the game so
when Joe Biden gets in he has to shut
down Donald Trump's make America great
plans because what Donald Trump is doing
uh-oh he's bringing manufacturing back
he's securing our borders he's making us
energy independent so that we can have a
good economy here people like Joe Biden
and the Deep State establishment
whatever you want to call it they want
Global control they want war they want
Conquest they want unipolar Global power
so they're going to say no no no we got
to give more of American resources away
to ensure that people are beholden to us
is this this might seem like a stupid
question is it one of those things where
like if we're uh with the us being so
involved militarily in other countries
uh is part of our involvement uh helping
other countries with our military is
part of that under the expectation that
they will continue to trade in US
dollars
well yeah of course yeah uh Ukraine for
instance Biden threatened to withhold a
1.3 million dollar loan from the IMF
billion billion 1.3 billion yeah that's
what I meant to say thank you um what
was happening is the IMF was going to
loan it to the Ukrainian government and
the U.S was going to
um what are they called back it say like
if they if they default we'll pay it and
then Biden was like we're not going to
back it if you don't fire Victor shoken
and they were like well uh off oh
sir pardon me and then so then he was
like no it's I'm serious and so they
fire Victor it's crazy when I was
watching that clip because uh even my
assessment of the barisma Scandal is
nowhere near as in depth as that guy's
assessment was when he's breaking it
brilliant Rob knower is his name they
they mycolas lachevsky's funds were
frozen under this encryption
investigation and the government passed
some provision that unfros them and
Shook and immediately rushed in to get
his asses Frozen again because they were
going after him Joe Biden comes in says
fire the prosecutor they they they
didn't fire him out right he ended up
getting or he was forced to resign
somewhat later on I think it was a few
months later and then the new guy who
comes in that binds again he's solid
new guy clears launches give all
wrongdoing assets are unfrozen slachesky
returns to Ukraine to begin his work
once again
Donald Trump gets elected starts
investigating what Joe Biden did
zlachevsky flees Ukraine once again yup
these people are evil corrupt
individuals that would sell out their
own mothers look at what Hunter Biden is
Joe Biden made him that and uses him as
some vessel to squeeze resources out of
his public career evil yeah it's just so
so despicable it is man where were you
Kevin when in 2015 when this was kind of
transitioning into the Trump years right
what was it like were you in Hollywood
at the time yeah yeah we left about five
years ago so I was definitely still
there were you like into politics were
you pretty I've always been in politics
and then what is what was your vision of
what was happening through the Obama
Administration in the second term and
then into the Trump years
um you know it was it was interesting
because I lived way out of Hollywood
I've never been a Hollywood guy I like
the industry I liked making movies and
TV shows I'll be creative process of it
but I never really fit into Hollywood
because I'm not I'm not the ass kisser
that you need to be in that industry and
um I just I I didn't really see it until
I did these charity golf events that's
when you see it because 80 of the actors
there were obviously Obama supporters
and uh you know they're the bashing was
going on but I was the one who always
questioning if they say something
negative about the Republicans I go what
about what Obama's doing and it was I I
didn't like try read a fine line because
by then I was already kicked out of
Hollywood they knew where I stood and I
said a charity golf event for Joe Namath
up in uh in Long Island last week and
the guy the actor I'm going to mention
his name but he's very very far left
nice guy but he was having a hard time
golfing with me just because I'm not far
left and it's interesting it's so weird
because I don't Harbor that kind of
anger I don't to me it's like dude
what's up with that conversation about
it I'm not going to try to change your
mind but let's have a real conversation
and it's difficult to get that from the
left because they feel if they yell
louder at you that they're correct
that's the weird thing also it's a
charity golf tournament do you have to
even have the conversation just go be
polite to one another and move on with
your life yeah you know I asked look I
asked him I got a movie coming up in in
October and that I directed beautiful
movie It's called miracle in East Texas
please check it out it's
miracleestexes.com and um It's a
Wonderful movie it's a true story and I
asked him hey would you do an
endorsement for it and he goes well is
it like is it got like a Faith Message
to it I don't care but then why why ask
that yeah so you brought up earlier when
people ask questions or they say
something they're the defense like well
um you know he's uh Epps isn't working
for us well we didn't we didn't say that
he was why are you defending yourself
with that so it makes you wonder about
what they're saying so I had a hard time
getting them to want to even give an
endorsement for my movie and we're in
the same industry and I said look I got
a wonderful cast of John ratzenberger
Lou Gossett Jr Tyler Maine it's a
wonderful true story it's won 10 10 film
festivals so I was telling people right
now please go I gotta get my plugin for
it go to sorbelstudios.com actually
there it is we got we got it pulled up
tell us about what's going on it's a
true story set in 1930 and it's about
the largest oil found in the history of
the world true story it was about two
con Men played by myself and there's
John ratzenberger just the other side of
me there and next to Lou aluga said and
they would go through Oklahoma and Texas
wooing widows out of their money on fake
oil wells they would sell 500 of the
shares declare dry Hulk going to the
next city they get down to Texas in the
Kilgore area they strike oil by accident
largest oil fine in the history of the
world I'm not giving anything away
because it's a miracle in these Texas
there's other little miracles happen
along the way but it's it's one best
romantic comedy best faith film family
film uh the judge's favorite it's an
amazing movie we only got two days it's
a fathom movie and fathom gets
independent movies out there when 750
screens but we need people if you buy
tickets right now to sell this sucker
out we'll get more dates it's a PG film
you can take your six-year-old and I saw
that it's got the pay it forward method
too if you want to buy tickets it's a
wonderful true story and you'll laugh at
it it's just it's it's great and it's
really eventually it's how the hunt
family became so wealthy
hunt what family is the hunt family the
hunt family well they became very
wealthy the two Hunt Brothers owned the
Kansas City Chiefs since the 1980s so
wait wait these guys were ripping people
off and accidentally were right they
accidentally struck oil and it was just
and my character wants to get attacked
on a Dodge John ratzenberger looks just
like the real guy in real life his
character
um he won dad Everett was was his name
he wanted to stay and said look we're
going to bring oil in US dude we sell
500 of the shares you can't have a 500
of the shares and we ripped off all
these other people now these other
cities he goes I'm an oil man I'm going
to do this and of course we get arrested
it's during the court case and all the
widows come down to see us get get hung
basically
um and uh it's just a very fun movie dan
Gordon is the guy pictured just to my uh
to my right as I face it Dan Gordon
wrote this he's an Oscar nominated
writer he wrote hurricane for Denzel
Washington wider up Kevin Costner wrote
60 episodes of Highway to Heaven with
Michael Landon wow and that's my wife
next to me she's in the movie She
produces a movie with me and uh it's uh
it's a wonderful wonderful family movie
so please for all those fans that keep
saying please make more movies like this
I don't have a 100 million dollar
advertising budget like avatars do we
need Word of Mouth more than anything
else so 39 days still comes out yes
what's the October October 29th and 30th
and if we sell out these theaters
they're going it's going pretty good
right now if we sell them out we'll get
more days but this at least gets us in
the theaters and that's what fathom is
able to do for independent movies what's
fathom fathom is a company that gets
gets movies like my independent movies
in theaters documentaries gives you two
days you got to get out there and really
hit the hit the pavement to do promotion
work I've already done probably 80
interviews in the last three weeks with
another another 80s to do before the
thing comes out so that's why I'm on the
road right now doing it they do a great
job to get it out there but it's up to
me to do the promotional work and I
appreciate you guys giving me a plug for
it because this movie is great for the
whole family you will love it and it's a
true story which I absolutely love all
the music is is 1930 or earlier all the
cars in 1930 earlier and one of the
trains it's about an hour and 45
one of the two working trains in all of
North America pre-1930. wow oh nice so
we got to use the train what's good
production about it what's it what is it
is it 30th a Saturday
uh no I think it's I think it's a it's a
Saturday Sunday isn't it oh okay even
better yeah let me uh let me double
check anything under two hours oh no no
no it's Sunday Monday it's Sunday my
Sunday my Sunday Monday so we get more
days obviously we'll get more more time
for it to get out there but like I said
great movie John ratsburg is awesome in
it uh Luke I said Junior the guy in the
beard in the far left that's Tyler Maine
a lot of people that are no WWF guys he
was a very famous wrestler back in the
80s and 90s and he was um he was saber
tooth and the X-Men movies and he's
Jason
he was great in this and as I told you I
love doing true stories and this is just
another really wonderful story and a
wonderful Dan Gordon script do you like
acting or directing better
um I started directing back on Hercules
by season three when I walked into
Universal I said hey talk to Sam Remy
was our exact producer I said Sam Ramey
was the executive producer yeah evil
dads and he did all the first two
Spider-Mans and I said I can I'm gonna
direct he goes okay and I went
well okay thank you I thought there'd be
some kind of fight that I was kind of
ready to go but I started directing back
then I love the direct
um I did another movie early this year
called Left Behind rise of the
Antichrist lap band is based on the 80
million Left Behind books it's written
by Jerry Jenkins right now his son
Dallas Jenkins is doing the chosen which
went to the fathom out as well the
chosen's doing really well massive
massive and they raised all their money
from people they raised 30 40 million
dollars from people so it's outside the
Hollywood system and um I I still if
you're going to give me a choice I'd
still love acting more but uh I I've got
four of the movies in post-production
right now so I've been I've been staying
busy are you acted in or directed I
acted I directed one other one but I I
acted in the other ones and I got two
documentaries that I produced that are
coming out later this year as well we
were talking about last night about uh
The Disaster Artist movie with uh James
Franco and James directed it and acted
in it right and how do you overcome as a
director and an actor like uh the
difficulty of not seeing yourself acting
as you're directing like do you how did
you go back and watch the
um I I trust usually I have ads that I
love to use and my wife is very smart
producer as well I trust their opinions
when I finish the scene but I usually
know I can get I can find myself I go
I'm acting right now I'm not doing a
bigger job but um I like to work fast
I'm a Believer in the way Clint Eastwood
Works he shoots eight hour days and
makes oscar-winning pictures I don't go
beyond I think make 12 hours top apps
but you start wearing these directions
that do in the 16 hour days you don't
have to there's a lot of wasted time on
sets as you know I mean there's just a
lot it's a lot of hurry up and wait yeah
there's but then it's like I I I'm like
another ID in the set what are we
waiting for what's going on so I always
want to work with people that work quick
I want to DP that noses lighting the dpu
out here was great we shot this in
Canada actually and I showed this movie
to a group of people in in Texas and
they go I know where that was I said no
you don't I was literally just gonna ask
where and he said yeah so what once
again it's Show Business not show show
they got a bigger tax credit they get a
bit dollars more stronger up there the 3
000 acre ranch that we shot in okay if
you're looking East you're looking at
the Rocky Mountains in downtown Calgary
you're looking West it looks like it
looks like Texas and that same that same
location we shot at Revenant was shot
there Leonardo DiCaprio they shot
Lonesome Dove there okay they shot open
range with Kevin Costner and they shot
clintus is Unforgiven it's good enough
for Clint Eastwood that location is good
enough for Kevin's Circle
you'll love this movie it's just it's
just a lot of fun and make sure you
stick around for the credits because the
outtakes are hilarious and there's one
less thing that happens when all the
credits roll that I added that I think
you'll get a big laugh out of it first
yeah the story sounds awesome it sounds
sounds like a fun movie it's fun right I
like the I I like the story idea a fan
of your work but uh on top of that
we're dealing with an industry that
kicked you out not for no reason other
than your private personal life and
beliefs even though even though you are
uh you have the biggest show uh I I I
don't know
Hercules was the most watched show in
the world by season three we're in 176
countries Andromeda was 150 countries in
the in the number one shown first one
syndication in America so you are
a superstar you're making money for the
industry hands down and they say no you
not to believe these things so we're
getting rid of that we we should support
films like yours
so that we can tell that industry that
I'll refrain from swearing to please
please leave us alone please leave but
look at the movies they're putting out
there right now the Disney's looking at
a billion dollar loss this year more
than a billion dollars out of 20. I do
movies that are in the three million
dollar range I do movies that are fun
their family these are movies Hollywood
used to do movies that had hope and love
and laughing we were talking about this
we talked about this last night uh
Groundhog Day Masterpiece great movie
but what was the budget on that thing
super low right I mean it's just oh I
can't imagine they put they probably
shot there for 15 million it's it's a
it's a it's it's just good actors and
Comedians In This Place yeah and then in
20 out of the top 20 movies that made me
that made the top 20 in the box office
this year 10 of them financially lost
money
10 of them were bucks that were did not
make enough Indiana Jones is going to
lose about a terrible 800 million
dollars so I tried watching it it's just
I'm sorry well they make the woman the
big star again they took away Indiana
Jones from Indiana Jones and that's what
most of these movies are doing is this
emasculation of men it's just that women
are the big badasses the men are a bunch
of losers and the sad thing is is like
the the what you when you say 100
million dollar budget that's actually
the low end now like well that was about
a three that was a 280 million dollar
budget yeah the the ones without lost
money the ones that gambled on 200 to
250 million dollar budgets there was
others that were more than that uh
because coveted restrictions ended up
setting people back a lot larger time so
out of those top five movies four were
all 100 million dollar movies that ended
up making extreme amounts of money
because they did good marketing at the
bottom end of that list you have sound
of freedom and two horror movies all of
which spent less than 16 million dollars
to make 100 over 100 years was about
14.5 million dollar budget I saw the
movie three years ago Jim caviezon had
the same manager for a year so I I saw
the movie a while ago they made it five
years ago and uh and that movie they had
a bite back from Disney because Disney
sat and did nothing with it so they
needed to make 50 million to break even
and they did and I had 175 million it
made more money than Indiana Jones
you know what field that number one
Angel Studios Angel Studios has been
chosen they go on they got they got I
don't know 100 million people that you
know watched them and they said support
this movie so they did Hollywood came in
and attacked the movie so basically
Hollywood said hey
we don't want we're not against child
sex trafficking we're for it we're
pedophile and I think there's it made
people angry on the left side and the
right side there's plenty of people that
are atheists like kind of people that
are on the left they don't want child
sex trafficking either so they went to
the movies if there were if there were
some some Communists who made a movie
yeah and they had conservative actors in
that film and they were trying to make
the story of a young communist on an
adventure and it was a very ideological
film but they were super chill and being
like hey man we don't we don't want to
judge you we just want to you know make
a film I'd have respect for that but
it's it's worse they're making over
budget bad movies regurgitated movies
while telling you that you are not
worthy to be in their presence so I say
screw them we support people who are
nice and who believe in good things and
so whether it's sound of Freedom or
Miracle in East Texas these are the kind
of movies I would much rather pay to see
and pay extra to see and pay it forward
for other people to see simply to tell
I'm gonna refrain from swearing these
jerks to to shove off if they were nice
I I'd say I'm sorry your movie didn't do
well but they are not nice people they
are mean and nasty people so they don't
deserve success
when you were getting like you said you
got kicked out of Hollywood I'm the
first uh cancel culture before it became
a term yeah did you get in an argument
with the wrong producer one night or
something no I think it just came in
there I was being known all on the
internet it was me posting stuff just
saying hey what about this what about
that what do you mean about you know I
mean any kind of topic I would bring up
and just say well why don't we look at
the other side of the issue you know
global warming why don't we look at the
other side there are a lot of scientists
who say the complete opposite I mean to
me it just and that's just one example
but and so they said we can't work it
anymore because I said wow because
Hollywood you know screams for tolerance
be tolerant of the issues we're talking
about you know and they put these out
there and people aren't tolerant because
they said they're enough of it people
don't care really I I when I get called
I could call it homophobic and it cracks
me up I've been to business 40 years and
I worked a gay person on every set I've
been on you won't find one yeah that
says oh my gosh he was so mean to
Medieval I wasn't they could come out
now and say so because obviously you
know about 25 years later and make it up
but that never ever happened but
Hollywood is just the way they are and I
said fine I walked away and said I
formed Sorbo Studios go to
serbostudios.com you'll see the amount
of work that I've done that my wife has
done it's uh you know I'm gonna keep
doing the movies that make people uh
talk about them in a positive way with
none of the Hollywood funny accounting
have you been working with your wife for
a long time yeah we actually met set a
Hercules she hates when I say this
because every every episode of Hercules
they brought you know they brought down
a hot babe for me to work it was a great
day it was a great dating service for me
and then I met her at the end of season
four and honest to God it was like
lightning strike it was like the
lightning strike you showed us earlier I
was like boom this is the one and I I
had to wear down she says I don't date
actors she said but and I had long hair
then she goes I don't date people long
hair and I said I'm making a good lip
with it right now so but um you know
it's uh she's we get along great 25
years when married she's like a producer
she works mainly as a producer she's an
actor two producer she's a writer she's
a homeschool Advocate I think I brought
up she's written four books on it and
she wrote a book called
um words for warriors which is really
you know okay you need you need to fight
to defend your position on on what the
attacks that the left has against the
right and so it's it's she's she's a
brainiac she was a biochemical
engineering major at Duke I was and I
went to college for a whole different
reasons yeah were you theater did you no
I double double business major oh cool
yeah uh do you is this the type of thing
where what's going on right now because
of the writers and actor strikes so you
had to get a waiver right to do it I
didn't get a waiver just to even talk
about this movie even though he shot it
a long time ago yeah wow and I said
they've never done that before this is
the first time they went to everything
but we got it pretty easily you know
what the SAG has still been a great
Union for me I gotta say they they
they've given out at least 150 waivers
other independent movies so if you're
independent of Hollywood this is our
movie it's nothing to do with anybody in
Hollywood it's independent that's
independently funded it's nothing to do
so we were able to get it otherwise we
wouldn't be able to talk about it here
right now wow but that would stop you
basically crazy they wouldn't be able to
talk crazy
they used to go after stop current
Productions the ones coming up now
they're saying no you can't even you
can't even promote movie that was done
so but so why why for someone starting
today why join the Union
um well you know what they're gonna
they're gonna solve the issue he'll be
done I don't know how much longer they
can do it but you know we get producers
in Hollywood they're making 50 million
dollars a year this guy came on I can't
remember which Bozo was he said well I
hope you actors starve and lose your
housing yes there's a lot of actors that
are living from month to month trying to
get a gig and he's for these guys to say
that is pretty ridiculous but where's
the union to protect people when they
get fired from their jobs for their
political views uh that's true that's a
good question I mean because if if if
they're doing right by you even now they
when when when a network or a studio
comes to you and says because of your
views like uh Gina Carano yeah was she
in the union is she yeah they should
immediately step in and be like no
you're not doing this because
yeah they should shouldn't they but
unfortunately most of them are on the
left of the side as well and if that's
the case I don't understand why someone
would want to join the union well in
Hollywood it's really not as much about
getting fires about just not getting
hired again and that's not exactly so
because most most people if you look at
the average salary of an actor I think
it's less than twenty thousand dollars a
year Well if Tom Cruise is making 20
million how many people had to make zero
to average that down to twenty thousand
a year you know what I'm saying there's
a lot of I was very fortunate I never
had to work another job then we we have
to displace that industry we have to
strip them of their centralized control
over this and I'm gonna go see your
movie thank you so much when you went
out to Hollywood did you just crush it
immediately I I worked I already had the
side card the important the important
thing is getting that screen access
Guild cards so during college
Minneapolis is home to headquarters the
target 3M Honeywell Pillsbury Best Buy a
lot of ads so I did a lot of commercials
during my college year so I already had
a very good commercial tape and I had my
screen access card so that already
opened the door I had no problem getting
an agent I shot over 150 commercials in
my career I never ever had to bartend or
wait tables I was very lucky because
most of my buddies were selling cars or
bouncing or whatever I didn't have to do
that did you do a lot of uh scripted
stuff buy more Hercules
um no just just just commercials I mean
I did some talking commercial and stuff
but that that gave me the freedom and I
got I didn't know anybody when I went
out there I just you know everybody's an
actor so I was easy to find out what
acting classes to take I studied with
three coaches over six years before I
got Hercules that my last acting class
was me Brad Pitt Matthew Perry Charlotte
Ross I mean Brad Pitt I remember him
coming in with his his scene for Thelma
and Louise have you ever saw the movie
he's only in a 10 minutes wow he just
steals it and the next thing I know
we're on a break at uh in our acting
class halfway through it because Back
Then Brad was like a chain smoker and
he's he's like dude I just got a movie I
got a I got a movie called river runs
through it with Robert Redford well
bye-bye Brad you know from then on he
just he was gone amazing and Matthew
Perry I remember him doing a scene in
class I said I said I'd go to I go Brad
this dude should be in a sitcom well two
years later he's on friends so do you
think that when this all comes through
what do you think they'll end up like
where does the strike fall do they end
up uh acquiescing on I have no idea but
there's got to be something in AI there
has to be there's got to be some give in
there but it's you know because the
thing is the thing is this is a blessing
for independent Studios right now
independent filmmakers absolutely
because Netflix and Amazon need to have
new material every month they need new
stuff to keep their subscribers
interested so uh this is a blessing for
us I'm sure we'll we'll sell this to
somebody we're gonna go to super chats
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this YouTube channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.com click join us so you can
hang out with the Discord community and
talk with like-minded individuals and as
a member you get access to the
uncensored show and you can even submit
questions and call in and talk to us but
if you want to submit questions you got
to be a member of the Discord so let's
read what you all have to say Clint
Torres the first Super Chat says howdy
people howdy hey Clint there you go
all right Dingle dinglehopper says a
five dollar tip of the hat to based case
orbs when can we expect pool boy three
oh my gosh I did a movie called pool boy
which is absolutely ridiculous it was so
funny uh it was very much in the vein of
um like a um like a Zucker film airplane
Naked Gun and stuff like that and I I
didn't I did another one too we did a
move a spoof on 300 called Meet the
Spartans
it was directed by the uh the Epic movie
Date Movie Scary Movie I love Epic movie
when I saw 300 in the theaters I loved
it it was cool but my whole mind was
like they should spoof this thing
there's this giant hole in the middle of
Sparta and dogs and kids are falling and
dying every day so when they called me
up a month later I said dude don't even
tell me my role I'm there all right
Dakota Stan says Kevin do you think
Andromeda got a fair Shake
um no I don't think it did I mean it's
the first show Gene Runway wrote after
Star Trek I think the biggest mistake we
were the five-year run would have been
seven but a Tribune company at the time
owned this I don't know if you guys
remember maybe too young in 2005
um our last year Tribune company they
don't said Chicago won the bankruptcy
yeah so they had to sell off all their
they had to freeze all their assets
unfortunately we were one of them even
though we're the number one showing
first one syndication should have two
more years my biggest fight with them is
it should be called Star Trek colon
Andromeda oh because you put the Star
Trek just name on anything it brings in
more people said I don't get invited
here I'm the first Captain Captain Dylan
after Captain Kirk was created by Gene
Roddenberry I get invited in none of the
Star Trek conventions but it wasn't
actually Star Trek it was like it was it
was Gene rodberry Road right
it was it was it was thousands of years
Beyond Star Trek Into the Future so my
ship
would have kicked Andrew
and I've done and I've done Comic Cons
with both Patrick Stewart and and
Shatner I'm a foot tall in both of them
I told him my account I said you realize
I'd kick both your asses you're the real
kid no no freaking chance right on let's
grab some more I know it's Scott Bakula
though
oh yeah he was in another one yeah he
was in uh the first what was it do you
space nine or something original
whatever no he wasn't in Star Trek not
the original he was the one that was
about the original Enterprise Star Trek
Enterprise I think it was called Maybe
Star Trek Enterprise maybe what do you
got
let's read more Dr Jester says Tim is
right we must create culture I wrote a
book called Brotherhood of the revenants
on Amazon Solomon Kane uh wh 40K and
Lovecraft with real 1066 A.D England
history weather and time machine
matching too so he's got a YouTube as
well at Dr Jester shout out to those
creating culture which is also why y'all
should look up right now at Miracle in
East texas.com and search for your
theater where it's playing buy tickets
and go see it please do uh I I have a a
general uh
well how do you phrase this loathing for
Hollywood in you know just just for a
lot of reasons
we were talking about the other night
like where are all the good movies Joker
was the one we came up with right away
and now that we have Brett here we could
probably ask Brett we were asking name
like a real Masterpiece of a film that
you think is really good that will
people remember and I'm like Groundhog
Day is a masterpiece but what do we have
like that and then we're like Joker was
really good Joker was was incredible the
problem is most of the movies that come
out like my my main way of judging a
movie and I was like would I watch it
again like that that's right and most of
them the answer is no I didn't find any
of the movies that came out this year to
be particularly awful I just found them
for the most part to be very forgettable
and average which isn't always awful
like for me a lot of it is like going to
the theater right the ability to go to a
theater and be enthralled in the
experience as you're as you're watching
it that's big for me so I give a lot
more leeway but but in in you know since
2010 and right has there been has there
been a movie where you're like that's
Groundhog Day level you know what I mean
um since 2010. um um yeah there was a
couple that Clint Eastwood I liked
American Sniper I thought that was an
unbelievable movie sound of Freedom
obviously that sound of Freedom was
really good and and the the intro I'm
just like it's genuinely really really
good the beginning when with I guess
everyone's seen at this point with the
father and and going to his kids and
like you actually see that Narrative of
how they steal children oh it's
unbelievable wow it's like in the movie
Up you get that first 10 minutes that's
really really good where where you know
him and his wife and they grow the whole
yeah that was the best short film of of
my lifetime but the rest of the movie is
just garbled nonsense most of my
favorite movies are prior to 2010 but
but with a sound of Freedom that first
10 minutes is emotionally as jarring
it's you know watching that scene where
the dad loses his kids man but uh let's
read some more
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I don't
know if souls are a real thing but
there's no doubt the fake sack grown
babies will not have one if Souls make
us human what will they be yeah so the
FDA was meeting I believe it was today
to determine whether or not it is
ethical to grow humans in bags they're
called bio bags and they're saying to
start what they would do is premature
babies would be placed into these bags
to be artificially
you know just stated
until they're healthy and then
eventually we would just grow babies in
bags
I think it's nightmarishly dystopian wow
yes it's a little creepy very creepy I
think they'll still have souls yes
Thomas side bottom says would you kindly
shut up my new son Peter Robert he's on
his sixth day in this world and I'm on
my fourth hour of sleep in that time but
I wouldn't trade him for the world to
borrow a phrase forward the line
congratulations good Sir Thomas
sidebottom and shout out to the newly
newly birthed Peter Robert
all right Welcome To Earth nice job by
the fire sizes Oliver Anthony is a
booking agent he just moved a show to a
bigger venue a day earlier due to high
ticket sales now on a Thursday many fans
are asking for refunds since they can't
attend so speaking of books unplug mine
yeah I should what is it it's uh it's
called the the test of lionhood okay um
I don't know if you guys remember when
when uh Kirk Cameron knows the book and
people were bashing him to go to the
libraries wouldn't let him come and read
his book yeah because they'd rather have
drag queens read to their seventh and 8
year old kids and his book was just a
nice little kids book my book deals with
what I've seen me going on for a long
time this emasculation of men in movies
and television shows you look at all the
sitcoms through the decades the dad's
all is kind of fat and out of shape the
mom's a babe the teenage kids just make
fun of dad he's a pin cushion Homer
Simpson
that's a real example but you got I can
name other uh real shows of real actors
I'm not going to name it I'm not going
to aim but uh but no but it's just it's
just it's out there and movies always
portray uh men as women women now are
the ones of the big Superstars the
superheroes they save the day they the
men can't do anything and it's like this
book really is about letting boys be
boys in the world we live in today stop
telling boys that they they you know
help them become men strong men strong
fathers down the road and this book has
doesn't bash any race or gender it's
just a movie it's just a book about a
line club named Lucas that goes into the
woods with his two little sisters
they're playing out there all the time
his little seriously gets cut by a very
poisonous plant that he knows about he
can't get back to his dad in time
because he knows that his sister's gonna
die he's got to pass his his
insecurities and his fear and find
courage to go up the mountain and get
this one flower that will save her life
it's just a great kids movie go to
braybooks.com bravebooks.com they do
wonderful movies for four to 12 year
olds I do believe that that's why um top
gun Maverick resonated with so many
people because it was great oh this has
been so long since anybody it seems like
at the end of the movie it's like the
guy gets the girl and drives off into
the sunset on a motorcycle it's like
welcome back to the 80s this room so
well yeah it's the number one movie
there and actually like what didn't do
well was
um Mission Impossible dead reckoning but
that movie was also 20 minutes well I
gotta go Tom Cruise credit was too long
but I mean he's he a lot of the movies
he does you kind of got to go and maybe
he's left leaning I don't know but he
doesn't he keeps he keeps a pretty even
kill and puts out really good
entertaining that's amazing that movie
did exactly what Jack Reacher great
movie oh not just him but the the TV
show Reacher from 2021 really good that
guy's great it was unbelievably good
yeah but one of the reasons why I liked
dead reckoning so much is it did exactly
what uh Indiana Jones failed to do which
was introduce a female character played
by Haley Atwell that is actually
incorporated into the show into the
movie really really well without
emasculating his character exactly yeah
all right let's read some more we got
T-Rex Pet Shop he says mind if we join
you in anti-time square I've been
thinking of putting a pet vending
machine there and eventually open a full
store if it goes well please do the anti
the opportunity is readily available for
our Public School where and if that's we
end up calling it and uh you're all
welcome to join us in Martinsburg West
Virginia
that's where we'll we'll be headed and
uh hopefully it works out
Justin huttera says I named my character
Sheamus in Starfield suddenly my
inventory was full of stolen utensils
conspiracy do you see that you see you
see the Starfield video with the
potatoes there's uh there's a video that
went viral where they were showing the
physics and a guy opens a door and a
bunch of potatoes fall out because they
were like look how amazing the physics
in this game are
I've been I'm still playing Ballers
again three I'm having a blast it's a
fun game you can do the video games much
I do not my kids do yeah it's like the
the time Big Time the conflicts of
movies and video games are coming
together where you're gonna be like the
main character in a VR they make more
money than movies do yep oh also if
you're looking for a good movie that did
come out this year the the movie Gran
Turismo was really really really good
and you don't see a lot of sports movies
these days so that was I know of it I
haven't seen it yeah it was it was very
very good I would recommend people to
take a chance and go see that one all
right Greg comedy says I started a food
vending business in Gold damn Brewing
Kevin was a silent partner in the
brewery also resume that's true right on
we got a lot of super chats where
they're just people saying that they
absolutely love you grafti says you're a
childhood hero and you always will be
very kind man I'm I'm I was so I was
saying before the show I'm a little kid
I would turn on Saturday morning
cartoons this one makes me old you were
seven when we started filming yeah
so so I'm I would turn on like I mean
when I what was I watching when I was
like eight or seven eight or nine Static
Shock can in Pokemon but then Sunday
they wouldn't have cartoons Hercules
would be playing so then I just wake up
in the morning it's the weekend and
you're watching Hercules oh you know you
know what almost go ahead I was gonna
say Outer Limits when I was a little kid
oh I loved out of limits freak me I when
I was in college it was a 10 30 was
reruns of Twilight Zone 11 o'clock was
the reruns of Star Trek so if my parents
called me around the time I'm busy I'm
studying really hard right now but that
was like a big thing for me to do and I
I absolutely uh just I I loved those
those days and I loved being a part of
this uh Star Trek family I forgot to
tell you it was awesome dude sci-fi yeah
yeah sci-fi also is it is it true that
you were a runner-up to play Superman
um here's the thing I originally got the
roll oh my goodness 24 hours later they
called me up they gave it to Dean Dean
Kane and and three stole and three or
wrong but here's the thing here's the
thing so here's a three months later I
got I got the Hercules roll there you go
so I like to tell Dean you know my show
in seven years became the most watched
show in the world you show got Canada
for three seasons so I'm pretty happy
Lois and Clark that show yes Alison
Clark epic yeah epic and the girl Terry
Hatcher she played she played my wife we
did a three-show arc on Supergirl about
five years ago I still can't believe
that they they had you on Supergirl
given the the political stuff you know
what was interesting
the the one of The Producers 30 year old
producer she says now your character
Kevin is the most evil person in the
universe think
I think think Donald Trump
[Laughter]
I went okay so
you probably know more than I do but so
is Trump more I mean has he killed more
people like than Hitler I'm just curious
maybe you know more about history than I
do
um is he worse than Pol Pot or worse
than
I start naming those people I just kept
waiting you know she's kind of glared at
me and they kept you on let me find out
later that Where I Stood pretty quickly
and then she's got a Karma she was
fearful of me the rest of time because
you know I'm Kryptonite to Hollywood
well how did you end up getting that
role though I have no idea they just
called me up and said you know we want
you for this role I know yeah I think
Money Talks yeah and and what so one of
the issues is well they know that
they're getting more eyeballs on it if
I'm on it bang you know that that
bringing you in on this show is going to
get all the Millennials and everyone
would be like yo and they needed that
yeah this is this is my point about
building culture all of these people who
act like they're woke and they support
these causes they don't care they're
just saying whatever they think they
need to say especially in Hollywood so
they can get the roles and fit in can we
take that power away we we buy tickets
gets to your movie because you sound of
Freedom eventually these people will
stop talking can I tell you that every
movie I've been doing over the last like
six seven years I get whether it's an
actor a camera guy lighting guy come up
and say quite like a drug deal is going
on say dude thanks for being a voice for
us I say be a voice for yourself yes
this is the problem well I don't want to
get blacklisted like you you know what
they're not calling me for big movies
anymore but I'm still doing independent
movies here you are in the set of my
movie you know you so I you still work
but you're right Hollywood will never
call me in again for anything big on TV
or movies which is fine I'm with movies
how do they think Hollywood got started
do they think that Hollywood was started
by guys who are on the East Holly was
very conservative when it first started
but Warner Brothers Warner movie studio
told they were but totally totally but
it's not just that it's that they were
bucking the system it's that they were
excised they went to the far reaches the
middle of nowhere where they could do
the work they wanted to do you like the
idea they're people who are saying I
want to suckle the teat of the gigantic
decrepit machine instead of saying I
would rather get on a boat travel for 3
months with a you know 20 chance of
dying on the way there to land on a
Barren Shore and build a house in the
middle of the woods than live in your
crackpot Town those are the Pioneers who
came to this country that means if you
want to fight for what you believe in
they should be saying I'd rather work
for you and get paid less than work for
Hollywood because they suck yeah let's
get it are you guys go see miracle in
East Texas are you happier since you
went independent oh heck yeah I love the
moves I'm doing right now I never you
know I've been there a long time and
look I had huge success with Hercules
and Andromeda two huge shows and then I
had about five years of doing movies
within the Hollywood system and then uh
when this happened I said fine I know
enough people in the business I got a
lot of you know I can shoot anywhere in
America I can put a crew together so I
have no problem with that what is this
let's read some more Pedro says hey Tim
Fallout 3 remaster is confirmed is that
is that true oh wow Oblivion and Fallout
3 remastered IGN
oh wow I'm super excited for that I want
Morrowind dreaming I mean I don't I
don't care about the graphics the game
is awesome
but uh it depends on what they do with
the remaster I don't like Mothership
Zeta though was that was that what was
called the expansion in in uh in Fallout
I didn't care for the aliens yeah I know
what you're talking about I don't know
the name of it yeah Nolan bus says will
they arrest the D.C metro police who are
in plain clothes chanting go go body
camera footage Rhett Pagan said there
were feds dressed in Maga gear
pre-staged inside the capital before it
was breached wow what a representative
said that I know about the cops saying
go go and things like that yep
Bender the offender says Tim do you
think wages will ever catch up to the
rates of inflation no it depends if we
transition to a hydrogen-based fuel
economy we might be able to balance
things out I mean
no if it it is good if we Implement
newer and better forms of technology
Fusion hydrogen cell whatever fuel yeah
but but that's not going to change that
the FED is going to break it to extract
from it so that they can wage Wars you
know it is what it is
all right Jimmy Joe says Kevin I've
worked 25 plus years in Showbiz I've had
to keep my head down on my mouth shut
all this time where can I send a resume
serbostudios.com
studios.com check it out here's what
happens okay when when miracle in East
Texas sells out in every theater and
Sorbo Studios makes a ton of fat Cold
Hard Cash they start hiring all of you
bringing you into new movies expanding
the business and then Hollywood starts
crying saying oh no why did we ever get
rid of this guy he's a superstar and now
we're losing money and then we tell them
your dicks We're Not Gonna We're not
gonna do business with you anymore there
you go that's how you win I'm getting
hit up here a lot a lot of people are a
lot of people that like me and follow me
follow you oh right on man I'm glad to
hear it this guy right here caught you
and Tim cast tonight great show you've
got a great voice for Christian
conservative content God has gifty to be
a mouthpiece first kick them hit Kingdom
hit me up if you need a place to film is
is Miracle in East Texas it is a faith
film it's Loosely based on faith but
it's not like it's like Blind Side you
remember Blind Side people okay if there
was a movie with um Sandra Bullock the
football player that's in the news now
because it's in the news because he's
saying I was but anyway it was it was it
was a movie that if you a person of
Faith who wasn't a great faith family a
Christian family in Texas took on that
blackhead he went on to become the Hall
of Fame football player true story so
um people have non-faith said no that
was a great football story so it's in
there but it's not like it's not like a
better believe in Jesus movie it's a
it's a movie that everybody can see and
you'll just enjoy it for the true story
that it is I mean
I watched the passion for the first time
a couple months ago pretty intense and I
I recommend it for a lot of people
especially if you're not religious
because of the historical well that's
just it right every atheist uh that you
know I did a documentary with John
Lennox he's an apologist from Oxford
University I highly recommend it's
called against the tide he's debated all
the great atheists of the world from a
singer to Dawkins Hitchens all these
guys they don't deny that Jesus wasn't a
man that lived on this world they did
not deny that so the history is there
and it's literally fascinating the the
for me so I I believe in God I'm not a
Christian uh I watch this and I I
thought it was I thought it was a great
film it's depicting actual history yeah
so I started looking these these stories
up uh the the
um what was it Barabbas the murderer I'm
probably getting the name yes yes and
and these things I should have learned
when I was at the Catholic school and I
was like a pilot said which of these two
people should I say which do you want to
crucify yeah yeah and so so the audience
I started looking up history books and
it was like oh yeah all that happened
yeah the Christians just believed Jesus
was the son of God outside of that it's
all true and I'm like oh wow like I'll
tell you what I'll tell you what I do a
trip every year to Israel I host 80 80
people if you want to go to Israel
and anybody out there this you can be a
trip of Lifetime it could be a bucket
list saying go to Sorbo israeltrip.com
that's horrible israeltrip.com and check
it out you guys will absolutely it's an
amazing journey into Israel and I've
shot two documentaries there as well
what do you do when you go there you
just see you see everything I got three
amazing guides that that bring us along
and two different buses and it's just
unbelievable the stuff you'll see I've
been there five times now let's read
some more
what do we got uh
let's see
Papo Naya says literally every day I
have to manually search for this show no
cap No Cap wow well that means it you
know that's that's how we know it's true
a lot of people uh here's the crazy
thing it's one thing if the show if you
watch every night and it doesn't appear
on your homepage because it should the
algorithm should be like hey this is a
show you like but there are people who
said they'll go to our YouTube channel
at the time of the show and it's not
there
even though we are alive because we
don't miss shows however there's also
timcast.com we always embed the player
automatically on the top of the home
page as well as Pop Culture crisis we
got a couple new shows we're launching
very soon we got the skate show we're
gonna be skating tomorrow and filming
and then we're doing a
um weird and wild conspiracy mystery and
unsolved mystery show that's coming up
soon really excited for that one
supposed to be a year ago but man hey
anybody who's run a business where they
had to do construction they're probably
sitting at home laughing being like ah
this poor young guy I thought he was
going to build a studio and get it all
done a few years later but I it's like
we're in New Territory I can only
imagine yeah
what do we got we got some super chats
here
Dustin Weiser says thank you for
teaching us strength as Hercules and
proving strength holding on to your
convictions very cool absolutely very
much
let's see Scott Jeffers says I've heard
Kevin say a few movies he's been in
after he's been exposed as a
conservative where can I find these
movies and support
I'm sorry boy Israel I mean this road
trip I got that in my mind Sorbo
studios.com everything's there all my
movies are there you can get signed copy
for me if you want from me my books are
there I got true strength and I got true
Faith two wonderful books and then I got
this one course
um but uh yeah Sorbo studios.com is a
good place to go were you like um raised
in a religious family or did you find I
was no I was I've been kind of Christian
all my life I don't know I haven't led a
perfect life there's no doubt that about
that and uh but I I don't go out and say
I'm better than anybody else I just uh
it's always been part of me I look at
this and go guys I mean like who made
this table right somebody made it right
yeah that's right somebody made it it
wasn't you wasn't me started somewhere I
don't have all the answers but I look up
at the stars and go okay guys this
didn't just happen something caused it
to happen this table was three different
pieces of wood that were brought in
through I think the window wow because
they're they're a long that's big yep
and then it was it weighs like a
thousand pounds I think I believe it
yeah and I was like worried about the
floor and like now you're fine
something's causing it to happen right
now that's appearing it just appeared
what is causing the vibrations or the
fluctuations or the spin I don't know
what or why I just but it's I mean
people don't realize how big the table
is because when you're watching from the
cameras you only see us yeah and the
cameras are showing you and the cameras
are zoomed in so people will walk in the
studio for the first time they go whoa
it's huge and I'm like yeah it's like
well I I huge that'd be what 18 feet
long or so and uh 18 by six yeah made by
eight I think that's big no that's like
18 by five I think the room oh that's
more than five the
yeah yeah you're right you're right yeah
there's like a whole wings but maybe I
don't think it's exactly six feet it's
big though it might be six feet yeah it
might be six by eighteen or something
the room itself is I think it's 35 by 16
or something like that that'd be about
right yeah 35 by 16. I don't know people
people come in they're like wow it's so
much bigger than I than I thought it's
so much more gigantic
what do we have here let's uh
uh Terence Max says Kevin touched my
elbow once at Comic-Con in Montreal in
2007 and it was the best day of my life
at that moment
your fans do you you give them like a
word of kindness and it can completely
change it when I do Comic Cons I love
the fans I mean without fans we don't
got a career and people have been so
nice to me at these Comic Cons and uh
but but here once again the cancel
culture comes in right this woke stuff I
mean I was supposed to do two Comic Cons
in in uh in last November in Australia
and I've been there three times and the
Australian fans have been huge
supporters huge fans
I got banned to come there because they
got 10 emails from fans saying if he
shows up we're gonna Riot wow and I said
you have 50 000 people coming there yeah
I'm not worried about it these people
probably aren't even gonna come to the
con regardless yeah and you're going to
let them control me being able to come
out and have a good time and they did
they they wouldn't let me come out wow
let's read one more we got vexkin kilrog
says if I remember right Andromeda was
supposed to be set in the Star Trek
universe
is that true
um it was it it was all I know is a Star
Trek show were created by Gene
Roddenberry it wasn't really in the Star
Trek universe because it was supposed to
be thousands of years into the I think
it was like 8 000 years Beyond Star Trek
but so so theoretically so it is in the
same yeah yeah because yeah because it
was Gene Roddenberry so it was certainly
part of it they could have they could
have was it a legal thing they couldn't
use the name or something I think he
just came up with a different name for a
different show at that time you know and
I think too it probably gave him
contractual uh uh like Star Trek's
probably got rights and ownership it was
a huge mistake for Paramount to take
that off but back then you only had
three state you had you had well you had
PBS but yeah ABC CBS and NBC if you're
not pulling in roughly 30 they're
getting 25 rating nothing gets 25 today
so there was a big mistake to get rid of
that show all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com to watch
the members only uncensored show which
will be up in a few minutes and you as
members you can submit questions call
into the show it's gonna be a lot of fun
you can follow the show at timcastirl
you can follow me personally at timcast
Kevin do you want to shout anything out
uh once again serbostudios.com for
everything Kevin Sorbo go there support
movie The Miracles Texas information is
on there and uh pray books is on there
and all my movies and books are on there
so Sorbo studios.com great place to go
right on uh actually before we go I have
to make a correction on something I said
earlier the cardi B thing I was wrong
about
um and she's actually sued someone for
that before so she is uh about being a
hooker like she's that's not something
that's been proven she was never never a
hooker so that was a misspeak on my part
she there there is the her admitting to
doing the the drugging and robbing of
men but she was not a hooker and so she
actually won a lawsuit so I have to make
that oh wait wait so so wait wait so in
in what context was she drugging and
robbing men uh I could pull the story up
right now but I just would say somebody
had been sued for that before so I
apologize didn't they do a movie about
that I don't know at all but this is my
Mia culpa so this is my fault but isn't
isn't isn't cardi B cardi B like saying
good things about like hasn't she been
fairly based on certain issues is it uh
I don't know like um like maybe on
vaccines or something like I'm not sure
yeah she's like defending people's
rights and stuff I mean Nicki Minaj
who's doing that uh but yeah like so
that was a misspeak on my part so I
apologize people were saying people are
sending me a message about it because
she won a lawsuit for like an extent
well I mean amount of money for that so
I just well just to make sure we're
clear that she wasn't selling her body
she was just drugging and robbing guys I
was I was I misspoke so I do apologize
so that it's my fault guys if you want
to follow me you can follow me on
Instagram and Twix at Brett dasovich on
both of those platforms you don't have
to worry about it because the actual
malice standard applies
you have to in order to fame somebody
who's a public figure to knowingly have
lied about them and if people are
reading these stories we mean no ill
will but yes I misspoke uh but also a
pop culture crisis is here Monday
through Friday 3 P.M Eastern Standard
Time that is noon Pacific join us right
here on YouTube guys and I gotta get my
Twitter and their case orbs go to k
sorbs ksrbs because Facebook put me down
but I'm very funny with my sarcastic
truth on Twitter on X I'm Ian Crossland
uh great to meet you Kevin awesome night
pleasure wonderful to hear about your
career and talk about the industry man I
love hearing about it thank you um you
guys can follow me at Ian cross on
anywhere in the internet there it is
behind me and check out at timcast.com
go around the left on the cast
castlevlog check out the most recent
episode Raymond g Comey Jr I'm gonna say
that again Raymond g Comey Jr that's the
name of the episode check it out Carter
Banks talk us out what's up guys Kevin
it was a pleasure having you on thank
you sir
feel like I just watched the whole show
just right here with pressing buttons in
real time enjoy filling in for surge
um yeah uh you can follow me at Carter
banks on Twitter follow Tim cast music
at timcast songs on YouTube and that's
all I got for now let's all right
everybody we will see you all over at
timcast.com for the members only show
thanks for hanging out